GOOD MORNING WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE HEARING A FEW
REMINDERS MASKS ARE REQUIRED
IN THE HEARING ROOM AND OTHER
COMMON AREAS THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITAL TESTIMONY CAN BE
PROVIDED IN PERSON AT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION
LOCATED OUTSIDE OF THE CAPITAL
AND BY PHONE THE NUMBER FOR
PHONE TESTIMONY IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO THIS NUMBER IS POSTED
ON THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE
AND ALSO APPEARS ON THE VIDEO
FEED ONCE THE PRIMARY SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION WITNESSES HAVE
TESTIFIED I WILL CALL FOR PHONE
TESTIMONY WE HAVE THIRTEEN
MEASURES ON THE AGENDA TODAY
WITH FIVE PROPOSED FOR CONSENT
ITEM ONE SB TWO FORTY FOUR
ARCHULETA ITEM FOR SB THREE
THIRTY TWO DODD ITEM FIVE SB
SIX SEVEN ONE GONZALEZ ITEM
SIX SB FOUR EIGHTEEN LAYERED
AND ITEM FOURTEEN ACR THIRTY
THREE FRIEDMAN WE'RE GOING TO
GO AHEAD AND START AS A SUB
COMMITTEE -- AND I'LL INVITE
SENATOR DOLLY TO PRESENT
SB THREE NINETY SIX THIS
IS ITEM THREE ON THE AGENDA
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT SB THREE NINETY SIX
WILL IS IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR
HAZARD TREE ABATEMENT FOR
UTILITY COMPANIES ALSO I THINK
THE CHAIR ENTER COMMITTEE
STAFFER WORKING TO ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS SURROUNDING THE
PROPOSAL AND I'LL BE ACCEPTING
YOUR COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
SB TWO NINETY SIX WILL GIVE
LANDOWNERS THE RIGHT TO
BE NOTIFIED BY THE BY AND
COMMUNICATE WITH UTILITIES AND
CLARIFY EVERYONE'S ROLE IN OUR
PROCESS TO PRINT WILDFIRE NEAR
POWER LINES IT ALSO UPDATES
IN MODERNIZE THE OLD CODE
SECTION ON THE TOOLS UTILITY
IN LOGGING CREWS ARE REQUIRED
TO HAVE FOR HAND -- HAVE ON
HAND FOR FIREFIGHTING REQUIRE
THE THAT BEFORE UTILITY CAN
REMOVE A TREE THEY MUST RELY ON
THE ASSESSMENT OF A CERTIFIED
ARBORIST OR TREE HAZARD
EVALUATION TOOL CREATED AND
APPROVED BY THE INTERNATIONAL
SOCIETY OF AB -- ARBA CULTURAL
CERTIFIED ARBORIST OR ARBOR
ARBORIST GIVE THE LAND OR THE
OPTION TO RETAIN ALL THE WOULD
ASSOCIATE WITH FELLED TREES AND
REQUIRE THE UTILITIES TO REMOVE
THE WOOD AT THE AT NO COST TO
THE LANDOWNER WHEN THEY REQUEST
INSURE THAT FELT WOOD LEFT ON
THE PROPERTY IN CASE IN CASES
WHERE THE LANDOWNER DOES NOT
REQUEST HAULING IS DONE TO SO
IN ACCORDING TO ALL APPS GOING
VIRAL A PUBLIC SAFETY RULES
AND REGULATIONS THIS DESIRE IS
THE DESIRES TO STREAMLINE THE
POLICY ENVIRONMENT ENVIRONMENT
AROUND WILDFIRE MITIGATION
REMOVE POTENTIAL DELAYS AND
OBSTACLES TO USE THE SEARCH
CERTIFICATE CRITICAL SAFETY
WORK MEARS THE ROUTE THE RECENT
EMERGENCY ACTIONS TAKEN BY THE
STATE LEADERSHIP AFTER YEARS
OF DEVASTATING WILDFIRES LET
ME BE CLEAR THIS BILL DOES NOT
GIVE THE UTILITIES A FREE PASS
TO CLEAR CUT TREES AS A MEANS
TO AVOID WILDFIRE LIABILITY
NOR DOES THIS BILL RELIEF
UTILITIES OF ANY LIABILITIES
ASSOCIATED WITH THE WITH ANY
COLLATERAL DAMAGE IN COURSE OF
THIS MITIGATING WORK IF THEY
LAND OWNERS DRIVEWAYS DAMAGE BY
UTILITIES EQUIPMENT USED DURING
THIS PROCESS OF ABATING H.
THREE HAZARD THEY UTILITY
REMAINS A HUNDRED PERCENT
FINANCIALLY RESPONSIBLE SB
THREE NINETY SIX SIMPLY HELPS
ENSURE UTILITIES HAVE THE
LEGAL AUTHORITY TO COMPLETE
THIS IMPORTANT SAFETY WORK BY
REMOVING LEGAL BARRIERS THAT
CAN PREVENT OR DELAY THEM
FROM DOING THEIR IMPORTANT
WORK AND PUTTING CUSTOMERS
IN COMMUNITIES AT RISK
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ALLOW ME
PERCENT THE THIS IMPORTANT
MAJOR DAY ON MITIGATION FOR
WILDFIRE RISKS IN OUR STATE I
HAVE VALERIE WITH P.
GENIE HERE TODAY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU I DON'T HAVE
ANY WITNESSES -- REGISTERED IN
SUPPORT -- BUT I SUPERVALU'S
HERE FOR TECHNICAL QUESTION
THAT'S TRUE OKAY GREAT THANK
YOU -- NEXT -- MOVED TO
JOHN KENNEDY RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
I BELIEVE HE'S HE SHOULD BE
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM HELLO
MY MISTAKE CHAIR I'M ON THE
PHONE OKAY IF I MAY PLEASE GO
AHEAD THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MY NAME'S JOHN KENNEDY I'M
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES
OF CALIFORNIA AND I'M NOT HERE
TO OPPOSE SB THREE NINETY SIX
-- BUT JUST TO ARTICULATE SOME
OF THE CONCERNS THAT WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS AND EXPRESS
THAT WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE OFFERING COMMITTEE
TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES SO LET
ME START BY SAYING WE SHARE
THE AUTHOR'S OBJECTIVES OF
REDUCING WILDFIRE RISK AND
AVOIDING LITIGATION STEMMING
FROM UTILITY EFFORTS TO REMOVE
VEGETATION THAT MAY FALL INTO
POWER LINES ARE MEMBER COUNTY
TO BE EXPERIENCED THE LION'S
SHARE OF DESTRUCTION CAUSED BY
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES AND WE
FULLY UNDERSTAND THE PRACTICE
NEED FOR UTILITIES TO INCREASE
THE PACE AND SCALE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT OPERATIONS AS WOULD
HAPPEN UNDER THIS BILL MANY OF
OUR RESIDENTS HAVE EXPRESSED
CONCERNS OF HOW SOME OF THE
EXISTING VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
WORK HAS BEEN CONDUCTED
AND SO WE SUPPORT SB THREE
NINETY SIX AS REQUIREMENT FOR
UTILITIES TO REMOVE FELLED
TREES AND LIMBS FREE OF CHARGE
UPON TIMELY REQUEST BY THE
LANDOWNER WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITMENT REFLECTS SEVERAL
OF OUR OWN SUGGESTIONS WE DO
FEAR THAT THEY INTENTIONALLY
BECAUSE SOME NEW ISSUES
THAT SHOULD BE RESOLVED AS
THE BILL MOVES FORWARD --
IN PARTICULAR WE BELIEVE
FURTHER WORK IS NEEDED TO ONE
OR FIND THE TYPE OF NOTICE
PROVIDED BY UTILITIES BEFORE
ENTERING PRIVATE PROPERTY
AND CONDUCTING VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT WORK TO ENSURING
THAT AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
LANDOWNER PART TO PROTECT THE
RIGHT OF ENTRY AND WORK TO BE
PERFORMED IS HEARD BEFORE A
NEUTRAL AND INDEPENDENT FACT
FINDER AND THREE CHOIR BY
THE LEGISLATURE'S INTENT AND
REPEALING PRC'S SECTION FORTY
TWO NINETY FIVE POINT FIVE P.
REGARDING LIABILITY WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE PROVISION
IN EXISTING LAW CONFUSING
AND DOESN'T REALLY ALIGN
WITH UTILITIES OBLIGATION TO
ENSURE THAT TREES OUTSIDE OF
THE EASEMENT DON'T COME INTO
CONTACT WITH POWER LINES BUT
AT THE SAME TIME WE THINK
IT'S ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT TO
ADD NON CODIFIED STATEMENT
OF LEGISLATIVE INTENT THE
DETECTION ISN'T INTENDED TO
AFFECT EXISTING LAW REGARDING
LIABILITY FOR COLLATERAL DAMAGE
OR NEGLIGENCE THAT MAY OCCUR
DURING THOSE OPERATIONS WE
REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHORS -- MR DALY AND
MR MADE TO ENSURE THAT THESE
CONCERNS ARE ADDRESSED TO THE
UTILITIES CAN PERFORM THESE
VITAL VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
OPERATIONS WHILE PROTECTING THE
DUE PROCESS RIGHTS OF PRIVATE
LANDOWNERS AND ENTERING THE
UTILITIES TERMINAL DOWN TREES
AND VEGETATION THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY THANK YOU SO NOW
WE'RE READY TO TAKE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION -- PLEASE JUST
STATE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL I'LL START
WITH THE HEARING ROOM GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE VALERIE
TRELLEBORG HOST PACIFIC GAS
AND ELECTRIC COMPANY THANK YOU
FOR THE WORK OF THE COMMITTEE
SUPPORT THE BILL ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU NEXT REMOTE
TESTIMONY LOCATION I DON'T
SEE ANY WITNESSES MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
YES THANK YOU IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
BEEN ZERO WE'LL GO TO LINE
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CRISTINA ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IN SUPPORT
OKAY JUST A MOMENT FOR OUR
NEXT ONE THANK YOU ONE MOMENT
SORRY FOR THE DELAY
ONE MORE MOMENT
COLLEGES WILL BE
JUST ONE MORE MOMENT
WE WILL GO TO ALIGN FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD YES HELLO
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS HAS
TO STOP WHAT YOU'RE BEHALF
FOR THE CALIFORNIA COALITION
OF UTILITY EMPLOYEES AND
THE STATE'S ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS IN STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THIS CRITICAL
CRITICAL LEGISLATION THANK YOU
THANK YOU WILL QUOTE ONLINE
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD MORNING
THEN THE CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND YOUR BECAUSE YOU
ARE WITH SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
SB THREE NINE SIX THANK YOU
THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU
I'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
SOME OF SOME OF OUR FLOOR
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK
YOU SENATOR FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD I KNOW THERE HAS
BEEN SOME CONCERNS -- WITH A
FEW FOLKS ON IT WITH THAT BEING
SAID THOUGH I CAN'T STRESS
THE IMPORTANCE OF ALLOWING OUR
UTILITY COMPANIES TO GO IN AND
FIX THAT WHAT WE ACTUALLY HOLD
THEM LIABLE IF THEY CAN'T IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT SO WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT RATE INCREASES
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT WILDFIRE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT ALL OF
THESE THINGS ARE CONNECTED
SO I ACTUALLY THINK THIS BILL
IS -- TIMELY IT'S INCREDIBLY
NECESSARY AND -- I'M PROUD TO
SUPPORT IT WITH THAT BEING SAID
YOU ALSO HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU KNOW THE PRIVATE
PROPERTY SIDE OF THINGS WHICH
I KNOW YOU UNDERSTAND VERY
VERY WELL -- BUT I ALSO HAVE
COMPLETE FAITH IN THE ARBORISTS
THAT THE UTILITIES EITHER
CONTRACT WITH OR HAVE ON STAFF
THEMSELVES THESE PROFESSIONALS
AND I THINK WE CAN WORK WITH
THEM AND WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT
WE LEAVE SOMEBODY'S PROPERTY
BETTER THAN WHEN WE YOU KNOW
WE GOT ON WE CAN DO BETTER --
THAN IT WAS WHEN WE GOT THERE
SO I APPRECIATE THIS BILL
AND THINK FOR BRING FORWARD
YES OKAY ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE P.
C.
NINE OKAY WE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM YET WERE OPERATING AS
A SUB COMMITTEE -- BUT I'D
LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS MEASURE FORWARD I KNOW
-- ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES --
INTRODUCED THIS BILL IS AN
ASSEMBLY BILL AND I'D LIKE
TO THANK HIM FOR HIS WORK ON
THIS WE HAD SO MANY BILLS --
IN THE ASSEMBLY AND LIMITED
I'M HERE IN TIME BECAUSE OF
COVE IT -- SO I'M GLAD THAT
YOU WERE ABLE TO BRING THIS
FORWARD AS A SENATE BILL IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE FAMILY
MEMBER MAYES THANK YOU WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I WOULD THINK
YOU APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
-- I I LOOK AT THIS MAY BE A
LITTLE DIFFERENT AS SOMEBODY
WHO IS A LANDOWNER IN A THIS
IS THE LANDOWNER RIGHTS BILL
TO ME MORE THAN IT GIVES THAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE LANDOWNER
TO KNOW THE CLEAR PATH OF WHAT
WHAT THEY HAVE THEIR RIGHT TO
IN THE PROCESS TO -- USE THE
PROCESS SO THAT THEY THERE'S
INDEPENDENT BODY THAT LOOKS AT
THE TREE AND SAYS HEY YES THIS
IS DEFINITELY A HAZARD AND SO
FOR ME I THINK IT'S MORE OF A
A CLEAR PATH I HAD A SITUATION
IN NEVADA COUNTY WHERE WE HAD
-- THEY STOP PRAGUE PROGRESS
IN THE THE WORKERS WERE AT RISK
THERE WERE PEOPLE THREATENING
THEM AND SO THIS REALLY CLEARS
IT UP AND GIVES IT A REAL
PASS OF THE OPPOSITION OR
THE CONCERNS THAT ARE CRC HAD
THIS WILL THIS BILL ACTUALLY
ADDRESS THEM AND GIVE THEM A
CLEAR PATH ON ON THE ON THE WAY
FOR SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
MY BELT I PER SHAKE OUT MIGHT
JOINT AUTHORS WELL -- WORKING
ON THIS ISSUE AND ASSEMBLY
BEFORE -- WE CAME OVER HERE SO
RESPECT AFTER ABOUT THANK YOU
FOR THE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
-- WHEN APPROPRIATE WE WILL
VOTE ON THAT MEASURE THANK WE
DO OKAY I BELIEVE WE HAVE A
QUORUM I'M SECRETARY Q.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
MEMBERS RIVAS HERE RIVAS THEIR
FLORIDA LARA HERE CHAU FRIEDMAN
GARCIA GARCIA HERE MATHIS HERE
MATHIS HERE MCCARTY RIGHT TO G.
SAY ARE CHAU HERE THEY ARE
STILL HERE STONE TONE HERE
WOULD WE HAVE A QUORUM Q.
IN THE OR CAN WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA FOR
SB THREE NINETY SIX SECOND AD
BUT I ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORIDA
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON ITEM THREE SB THREE
NINETY SIX BY SENATOR DOLLY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS RIVAS I
RIVERSIDE FLORA FLORA I CHAU
FRIEDMAN GARCIA RCI MATHIS
MATHIS AYE MCCARTY MURATSUCHI
SAY ARCHER HI THERE TOO I
STONE STONE I WOULD SIX ZERO
SIX ZERO WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN
SURE SECOND OKAY A MOTION
FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA SECONDED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
MEMBERS RIVAS I RIVAS FIVE
FLORA FLORA I CHAU FRIEDMAN
GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE MATHIS
MATHIS AYE MCCARTY MURATSUCHI
THIRTY FIVE SERTA EYES JONES
STONE I WOULD SIX ZERO SIX
ZERO WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS TO ADD ON
SO THE SERVER CASES PATIENTS
OKAY AND WE'RE GONNA MOVE
TO ITEMS SIX SEVEN SEVEN
I'M SORRY I'M ITEM SEVEN SB
FOUR FIFTY SIX BY SENATOR
LAYERED PLEASE GO AHEAD AND
START WHEN YOU ARE READY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- MADAM
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
I'M HERE TO AS WAS MENTIONED
TO PERCENT SENATE BILL FOUR
FIFTY SIX I WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS
AND APPRECIATE THE THOUGHTFUL
FEEDBACK FROM COMMITTEE STAFF
OBVIOUSLY OUR WILDFIRE HAS BEEN
FRONT AND CENTER IN IN NATURAL
RESOURCES AND IN THE STATE AND
THUS FAR -- THE LEGISLATURE
HAS REALLY STEPPED UP AND IN
FACT OF AB ONE SIXTY ONE OF A
BUDGET TRAILER THAT IS JUST NOW
OF BEING APPROVED ADDS ANOTHER
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
TO WILDFIRE RESILIENCE THE
RESOURCES AGENCY HAS RELEASE
THE CALIFORNIA WILDFIRE AND
FOREST RESILIENCE ACTION PLAN
WHICH SETS FORTH TARGETS OVER
FIVE YEARS OR MORE AND WHAT
TO DO ON PRESCRIBED FIRE AND
VARIOUS OTHER FIRE PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES THE LEGISLATURE
HAS BROUGHT FORTH THE MONEY
TO SUPPORT THAT PLAN BUT RIGHT
NOW IN STATUTE IT'S BASICALLY
WHATEVER THE LEGISLATURE
DOES EVERY YEAR IT IS NOT IT
IN STATUTE TO A MULTI YEAR
PROGRAM THAT MATCHES WHAT
OF THE RESOURCES AGENCY IN
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS PUT
FORWARD WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
BASICALLY TAKE THOSE GOALS AND
PUT THEM IN STATUTE THEN --
CREATES A BODY TO OVERLOOK THEM
EVERY YEAR HOPEFULLY ADAPTIVELY
MANAGE WHAT WORKS AND DOESN'T
WORK AND ALSO SETS FORTH FOR
THE FIRST TIME A CLEAR TRACKING
SYSTEM TO MONITOR THE NUMBER
OF ACRES OR THE ACTIVITIES
THAT ARE TAKEN IN REGARD TO
WILDFIRE OF PREVENTION AND
RESILIENCE AND SO THIS BILL
A REALLY PUTS TOGETHER IN
MULTIPLE YEARS WHAT HAS BEEN
DONE IN ONE YEAR THROUGH THE
BUDGET AND MULTIPLE YEARS IN
PLANTS THERE OUTSIDE OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S DIRECT PURVIEW
AND -- IT HAS BEEN A MOVING
TARGET TO SOME OF THE GOALS
OF CHANGED OR ADDED TO WE'VE
AMENDED AMEND TO THE BILL WE
HAVE TRIED TO DEAL WITH ISSUES
PEOPLE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
LANDSCAPE OF CHAPARRAL AND WE
HAVE THEREFORE AMENDED TO OUR
THAT IN THE BILL ALONG THE
WAY AND THUS FAR IT HAS BEEN
A BIPARTISAN UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL MOVING FORWARD FOR
THE FIRST TIME WE HAVE A COUPLE
OF -- LETTERS OF OPPOSITION
AND WHILE I SHOULD PROBABLY
REPRESENTS REFER TO THEM IN
THE CLOTHES I THINK IT'S GOOD
TO REFER TO THEM NOW BECAUSE
THE LETTERS DISAGREE WITH WHAT
THE LEGISLATURE IS DOING AND
THE ADMINISTRATION IS DOING
AND WILDFIRE PREVENTION AND ARE
USING THIS BILL TO OF FORCED
THEIR OPPOSITION WHEN BASICALLY
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD CHANGE
DIRECTION OR THE ADMINISTRATION
SHOULD CHANGE DIRECTION IF
THERE'S GOING TO BE A RESPONSE
TO THOSE CRITICISMS REGARDLESS
OF WHAT IS ADOPTED THIS BILL
PUTS IT IN A PLAN MULTIPLE
YEARS AND TRACKS IT IN A
CLEAR TRANSPARENT WAY GOING
FORWARD AS I SAID IT'S RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND NOT
A NO VOTE YET IN THE PROCESS
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAY
VOTE AND I KNOW THAT HERE IS
LIZ FORSBERG WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU WE ARE READY FOR
OUR ONE WE HAVE ONE WITNESS
IN SUPPORT ELIZABETH FORSBERG
FROM THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
MODERATOR CAME PLEASE OPEN
UP THE LINE FOR OUR WITNESS
SHARE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS WITH FORD BURKE
AND I'M THE ASSISTANT DIRECTOR
POLICY BUT IF YOU CONSERVANCY
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
FOUR FIFTY SIX FOLLOWING UP
RECORDS ONE MILLION ACRES
BURNED IN TWENTY TWENTY NEED
URGENT INVESTMENT PROACTIVE
MEASURES TO IMPROVE BALLPARK
GOING ACROSS OUR STATE IN
JANUARY GOVERNOR ISSUED AN
ACTION PLAN TO REDUCE WILDFIRE
RISK FOR GLOBAL COMMUNITIES AND
IMPROVE THE HEALTH OF FORESTS
AND WILDLANDS CALIFORNIA BOB
BYRON FOREST RESILIENCE ACTION
PLAN OUTLINES GOLDEN ACTION
IT CAN TAKE TO INCREASE THE
PACE CALIFORNIA RESTORATION
AND CREATE WEALTH BY HER
DOCTOR COMMUNITY BY CLINICAL
PARKING DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND
FIRE DEPARTMENTS PLANNING
THE ACTUAL PLAN ALSO BUILT
UPON CALIFORNIA AND -- YOU
FORSTER A JOINT FEDERAL STATE
AGREEMENT TO RESTORE HEALTHY
FOREST AND RANGELAND AND REDUCE
PUBLIC FIFTY REST THE MOU
AND THE ACTION PLAN PROVIDE
A LONG TERM GUIDE FOR THE
STATE TO REDUCE THE RISK OF
WILDFIRES AND IMPROVES STATE
AND FEDERAL COOPERATION BUT
WE NEED TO TAKE THESE PLANS
AND PRESIDENT ACTIVITIES THAT
WE CAN MEASURE AND ENSURE WE
ARE MAKING PROGRESS SB FORTY
SIX CODIFIES THE FRAMEWORK
OF THE MOU AN ACTION PLAN TO
GUARANTEE THE STATE HAS CLEAR
STRATEGIES COOPER PROJECT THE
BILL DEVELOP A COMPREHENSIVE
IMPLEMENTATION STRATEGIES TO
ACHIEVE THE GOALS THAT ARE
PART OF THE PLAN SB FOUR FIFTY
SIX OFFAL WINE THE ACTION PLAN
WITH THE STATE'S COMMITMENT
TO CONSERVE BIODIVERSITY
AND ACCELERATE FEATURE BASED
SOLUTION TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE THE BILL CARMODY REGULAR
UPDATING OF THE ACTION PLAN AND
REPORTS THE LEGISLATURE WHAT
IS IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE THE
STATE IS ACHIEVING THE GOALS
IDENTIFIED IN THE PLAN THE END
OF THE STATE BUDGET IF USED
TO ADVANCE THE MOST IMPORTANT
ACTION THAT CAN REDUCE CASH
OFF OF WELFARE WE APPRECIATE
SENATORS LAYER LEADERSHIP
ON THE ISSUE I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU -- NEXT WILL MOVE TO THE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WE HAVE
TWO WITNESSES RICK HELL SEE
FROM THE CHAPARRAL INSTITUTE
AND DAN SILVERMAN DANGER
HABITATS LEAGUE MODERATOR YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
OUR WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
-- LINES ARE OPEN THANK
HEY GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS AND STAFF IF YOU
RECALL THE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPARRAL INSTITUTE THIS
BILL SB FOUR FIFTY SIX
REALLY PROVIDES A WONDERFUL
OPPORTUNITY IF AMANDA TO
IMPLEMENT A NEW INFORM
VISION HELPS ALL THE WILDFIRE
CRISIS BY ONE VIEWING NATURE
AS AN ASSET INTO BY MAKING
OUR HOMES AND COMMUNITIES
THEMSELVES FIRES FOR THE
FIRST LOW WHILE HARD TASK
FORCE THE BILL TALKS ABOUT
MUST CONTAINS INVOICES THAT
WILL QUESTION THE STATUS QUO
BECAUSE AT THE MOMENT IT DOES
NOT THIS MEANS MEMBERS OF THE
SCIENTIFIC AND ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMUNITIES SECOND CHAPARRAL
GOT TO BE PROTECTED IT'S A
NATIVE TROUBLING SUPPORTS MUCH
OF THE STATE'S BIODIVERSITY
WE SUGGESTED LANGUAGE IN OUR
LETTER THAT WILL ACCOMPLISH
THIS THE SYSTEM IS ALREADY
SUFFERING FROM TOO MUCH FIRE
ANY MORE DISTURBANCES BILL
FACILITATES WILL ONLY MAKE
MATTERS WORSE IN THE LAST BY
THE MERCY INCREASING LIABILITY
BY THE SPREAD OF INVASIVE WE
THIRD CLEARING BURNING LOGGING
AND SPRAYING HERBICIDES ON A
HALF MILLION ACRES A YEAR IN
AN ATTEMPT TO CONTROL NATURE IS
NOT THE ANSWER THIS APPROACH IS
BASED ON CALPERS TUNNEL VISION
YOUR ANSWER TO RESOLVING A
WILDFIRE CRISIS IS A GOOD GROUP
WILL DOWN ON THE SAME STRATEGY
THIS LED TO THE LOSS OF
THOUSANDS OF HOMES AND HUNDREDS
OF WATCH THE WORLD HAS CHANGED
OVER THE PAST TWENTY YEARS
THIS REQUIRES A NEW INFORMED
DECISION NOT A REPETITION OF
THE SAME FAILED STRATEGIES THE
CALIFORNIA SUED FOR MORE THAN
A HUNDRED YEARS SO WE URGE THE
ASSEMBLY TO AMEND THIS BILL
AS WE SUGGEST I'M NOT PASSAGE
IN ITS PRESENT FORM THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
YEAH DO WE HAVE OUR
NEXT WITNESS ON THE LINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN IF THEY'RE ON
DANCE TO HAVE DOWN SILVER
NO I DO NOT SEE THEM LISTED
THEY ARE NOT ON THE CALL
OKAY SO WE WILL MOVE ON TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION PLEASE JUST
STATE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION
AND POSITION ON THIS BILL
WILL START WITH WITNESSES IN
THE HEARING ROOM GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR THE EXIT OFF YEAH
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR CHRIS
MCKAY LEE ON BEHALF OF HUMBOLDT
REDWOOD COMPANY AND MENDOCINO
REDWOOD COMPANY IN SUPPORT OF
CENTER LAYERS BATH THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL MOVE
TO THE PHONE LINES MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES
FOR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO
THE SP FOUR FIFTY SIX THANK
YOU IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS CHRIS ROSE
BEHALF OF KELP FORESTS THE
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASIAN IN
C.
MODERATOR DO YOU HAVE LINED AND
I'M SORRY ONE IT WELL THAT WAS
A WITNESS LINE AT INTERRUPTED
BUT WITHOUT LYING COMPLETED
I DON'T KNOW S.
B.
INTERRUPTION I DON'T KNOW
THE INTERRUPTION RECORD MY
CUSTOMER NOT THIS IS CHRIS
ROSA ON BEHALF OF KELP FOREST
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU OUR NEXT
LINE OF SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD HI GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR THIS IS MARK
FENSTER MAKER REGISTERING
SUPPORT FOR SEVERAL CLIENTS
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF RESOURCE CONSERVATION
DISTRICT LEAGUE LAKE TAHOE
AND THE WATERSHED RESEARCH
AND TRAINING CENTER THANK
SENATOR LAYERED AFTER I VOTE
WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
ON BEHALF OF STATE REP
LESLIE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
WE'LL GO TO LINE SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD MORNING
TERM MEMBERS JULIA HALL
WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD YES
GOOD MORNING THIS IS ALICIA
GONZALES ON BEHALF OF LOS
VIRGINIS HOMEOWNERS FEDERATION
WHICH REPRESENTS THOUSANDS
OF STAKEHOLDERS IN THE SANTA
MONICA MOUNTAINS WE OPPOSE
SB FOUR FIVE SIX AS IT IS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN AND SUPPORT
THE SUGGESTIONS MADE BY THE
CHAPARRAL INSTITUTE THANK YOU
SHE RECORDED LINE SIXTY
THE
LINE SIXTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN
AGAIN NINE SIX FOR
A CLOSE THE LINE
YOU MAY CONTINUE
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
MODERATOR ON THE LINES NO I'M
SORRY THERE ARE NO FURTHER
WITH OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT WE'LL MOVE TO
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE OKAY COMING FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SERETIDE CENTER
LATER THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD -- THERE'S NOTHING
MORE FRUSTRATING THAN WATCHING
THIS EVOLVE OVER THE YEARS
AND NOT HAVING A STRATEGIC
PLAN -- THE FIRST I THINK THE
FIRST STEP IN DEALING WITH
THE PROBLEM IS IT'S CREATING
THAT PLAN SO THAT YOU HAVE
A COORDINATED EFFORT BETWEEN
ALL OF THE DIFFERENT ASPECTS
INCLUDING THE CHAPARRAL THAT
-- ONE OF THE GENTLEMAN WAS
TALKING ABOUT THE FORESTS --
THE INTERFACE AREAS AND ALL OF
THAT -- IT IS A HUGE PROBLEM
-- AND FOR TOO LONG IT'S BEEN
A DISJOINTED EFFORT AND I
THINK YOUR BILL HELPS ADDRESS
THAT PART OF IT AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO GOING FORWARD WITH
THIS AND AGAIN AND HOPING --
FIND EACH OF THOSE EFFORTS IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE VARIOUS
PEOPLE THAT NEED TO DO THAT
SCALFARI OR PRIVATE LANDOWNERS
FOREST MANAGEMENT FOLKS --
BECAUSE WE DON'T GET A GRIP ON
THIS -- IT'S IT'S JUST GOING TO
CONTINUE YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER
YEAR -- -- IS THERE ARE YOU
KNOW THEY CHAPARRAL IT IS OUT
THERE AS ONE WHO HAS ACTUALLY
STOOD IN THE MIDDLE OF IT WHILE
IT'S BURNING LIKE FURY -- I
CAN TELL YOU -- THE MOONSCAPE
THAT ENSUES AND THE FLIGHTS IN
AND THE MUD SLIDES THAT HAPPEN
AFTERWARDS -- IS FAR BUT THEY
DID IT IT'S GOES FAR BEYOND
THE DAMAGE THAT IS CREATED BY
DOING SOME MITIGATION EFFORTS
LIKE THIS PLAN HOPEFULLY WILL
OUTLINE SO THAT WE CAN GO FOR
TO MAKE IT HAPPEN SO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING FORWARD A
PLAN ON SUPPORTING IT TODAY
AND -- I APPRECIATE ALL YOUR
WORK ON THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FLORIDA SENATE LATE I
JUST WANNA SAY THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD -- AN
ECHO PRETTY MUCH EVERYTHING
CHIEF HAS SAID -- HIS SERVICE
PALES IN COMPARISON TO WHAT I
HAVE DONE BUT I'M ALSO STOOD
IN THIS TWO THOUSAND THREE
WAS THE FIRST THE CEDAR FIRE
WAS THE FIRST MAJOR CAMPAIGN
COMPLEX FIRE THAT I ACTUALLY
WAS ON IN SOUTHERN PART OF THE
STATE AND IT WAS OVERGROWN THEN
IN ALMOST TWENTY YEARS LATER
WE STILL HAVEN'T ADDRESSED THE
PROBLEM SO IT'S INTERESTING
WHEN I HEAR THE CHAPERONES
TO SPEAKING ABOUT THE SAME
OLD FAILED POLICIES I THINK
WE POTENTIALLY SHOULD LOOK IN
THE MIRROR AND NOT TENNIS ON
CALIFORNIA NOT PIN THIS ON THE
MEN AND WOMEN THAT GO OUT ON
A DAILY BASIS AND FIGHT AND
RISK THEIR LIVES TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES TO FOR A PROBLEM
THAT WE AS A STATE AND QUITE
FRANKLY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
HAS HAD AN UNWILLINGNESS TO
ACTUALLY ADDRESS SO I ACTUALLY
APPRECIATE THIS BILL MOVING
FORWARD WE NEED TO DO FAR MORE
THAN WHAT WE'RE DOING BECAUSE
AT THE END OF THE DAY IF WE
ACTUALLY CARE ABOUT OUR STATE
OUR AIR QUALITY THE HEALTH OF
OUR FORCE ALL OF THIS IS PART
OF THE SOLUTION IS NOT THE ONLY
THING BUT CERTAINLY A PART OF
IT SO I APPRECIATE THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU -- CENTER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES IN
YOU ARE I KNOW I SHOULD JUST
ASK FOR AN IPHONE BUT BUT I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
FROM ALL THE WITNESSES AND FROM
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND I
SHOULD ACKNOWLEDGE ONE THANK
YOU NOTES ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE
AND I HAD A HUGE FIRE IT IS IN
OUR DISTRICTS LAST AUGUST HE
WAS ACTUALLY EVACUATED I WAS
PACKED AND READY TO GO AND HE
AND I VISITED A BURN SCAR TWO
WEEKS AGO AND AS WE WENT IN
WITH THE PEOPLE MOVES IN EIGHTY
EIGHT HUNDRED ACRE PARCEL THAT
WAS ALMOST COMPLETELY BURNED
OVER -- THE PEOPLE THAT MANAGE
TO LAND TOLD US THAT THEY HAD
DONE A PRESCRIBED FIRE NOT
LONG BEFORE AND THEN IN THE
MIDST OF WERE NINE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE HOUSES WERE LOST
THERE WAS ONE PLACE THAT SOME
HOUSES WERE SAVED AND IT WAS
PROTECTED BY THE PRESCRIBED
FIRE THAT IT HAPPENED NOT
LONG BEFORE THAT FIRE AND ONE
WITNESS SAID A HUNDRED YEARS
OF POLICIES AS IF THEY HAD BEEN
THE SAME AT ALL I WOULD SAY FOR
MAYBE EIGHTY YEARS OR EIGHTY
FIVE YEARS THERE WAS A POLICY
OF FIRES SUPPRESSION AND NOT
OTHER THINGS AND WHAT REALLY
HAS CHANGED THIS PRESCRIBED
FIRE FUEL MANAGEMENT LOCAL
FIRE SAFE COUNCILS IN ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS I ASKED IN OUR
BUDGET HEARING THIS YEAR IS
HOW MUCH OF THE FIRE PREVENTION
MONEY WILL GO TO LOCALS WILL
GO TO LOCAL FIRE SAFE COUNCIL
I GOT AMAZINGLY BIG NUMBER
WAS A SURPRISE IT WAS EIGHTY
FIVE PERCENT OR SOMETHING AND
SO THE REAL QUESTION IS IS
HOW WE NAVIGATE THAT SHIFT
IN RESPONSE AND HOW WE MAKE
SURE THAT WE ACTUALLY PLAN AND
HOW WE ACTUALLY TRACK WHAT IT
IS SO THAT WERE TRANSPARENT
IN WHAT HAS HAPPENED THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL DOES I WOULD
ASTRONOMICAL THANK YOU FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER FLORA AND I
DON'T HAVE A SECOND SECONDED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAY ARTURO I'M
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
LINE ITEM SEVEN S.
B.
FOUR FIFTY SIX BY SENATOR
LAYERED MEMBERS RIVAS HI
RIVAS III FLORA FLORA HI
CHAU FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN
AYE GARCIA GARCIA I
MATHIS MATHIS AYE MCCARTY
MURATSUCHI SERTA HI THEY ARE
TO AYE STONE STONE I WOULD
SEVEN ZERO SEVEN ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR SHOULD
LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
FOR FOR MEMBERS TO ADD ON
K.
SO WE WILL GO BACK IN THE
FILE TO ITEM NUMBER TWO OF
SENATOR CORTESE SB THIRTY SEVEN
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND THANK YOU FOR
TAKING ME OUT OF ORDER --
THEY TAKE A RESPONSIBILITY
FOR -- CREATING A COUPLE
MISHAPS THIS MORNING THAT
I'M I'M I'M ACTUALLY JUST
GOING TO BE HERE RIGHT NOW SO
THAT SAID -- PLEASE PRESENT
SB THIRTY SEVEN A BILL THAT
SAFEGUARDS PUBLIC HEALTH BY
PROHIBITING THE USE OF COMMON
SENSE EXEMPTIONS FOR PROJECT
PROJECTS LOCATED ON CORTEZ
OF THE SITES I'M GONNA KNOW
RIGHT THE BEGINNING THAT THIS
COMMONSENSE -- EXCEPTION A SOME
WHO'VE BEEN AROUND A SEQUIN
THESE ISSUES WOULD RECOGNIZE IT
AS THE GENERAL RULE EXCEPTION
WHICH WAS ITS ORIGINAL NAME
AND MORE RECENTLY HAS BEEN A
REFER TO US AS A COMMONSENSE
EXCEPTION THE CARD BECAUSE
HE LISTS ORIGINALLY CREATED
IN NINETEEN EIGHTIES BY THE
LEGISLATURE THROUGH THE EFFORTS
OF MY FATHER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FORMER SO MEMBER DONNA CORTEZ
HE IS A LIST OF CONTAMINATED
SITES CREATED BY VARIOUS STATE
AGENCIES FOR THE PURPOSE OF
COMPILING INFORMATION ABOUT THE
LOCATION OF HAZARDOUS MATERIAL
RELEASE SITES STATE LAW
CURRENTLY PROHIBITS CATEGORICAL
EXEMPTIONS FROM BEING GRANTED
TO PROJECTS IMPACTING SITES
LISTED ON THE CORTES LIST
BECAUSE OF CONTAMINATION ON
THE SITE POSE A SIGNIFICANT
RISK TO THE ENVIRONMENT HOWEVER
THIS WAS NOT BEEN SUBSTANTIALLY
REVISIT IN OVER A DECADE AS
A RESULT SOME LOCAL AGENCIES
HAVE SKIRTED THE LAW BY
GRANTING EXEMPTIONS PURSUANT TO
COMMONSENSE ALLOWING PROJECTS
TO BE CARRIED OUT WITHOUT GOING
THROUGH ADEQUATE ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW DOING THESE PROJECTS
WITHOUT PUBLIC ACCOUNTABILITY
AND APPROPRIATE CLEANUP POSE A
SEVERE RISK HEALTH RISKS LABORS
WORKING ON THE SITE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMUNITY THAT LIVE NEAR
THE SITE FUTURE FUTURE TENANTS
OF THE PROPERTY AND SO FORTH
SB THIRTY SEVEN CLARIFIES
THE WATER CAN FIRM THAT THE
COMMON SENSE EXEMPTIONS CANNOT
BE GRANTED FOR PROJECTS ON
CRITICIZING THE SITES THE
BILL ALSO PROVIDES A NARROW
PATH FOR PROJECTS THAT HAVE
BEEN CERTIFIED IS CLOSED TO
RECEIVE A CATEGORICAL EXEMPTION
IN ORDER TO STREAMLINE
PROJECTS THAT WOULD NOT HAVE
A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THE
ENVIRONMENT I WANT TO EXPRESS
MY STRONG COMMITMENT TO WORKING
WITH THE CHAIR TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE'S CONCERNS BY
NARROWING THE BILL TO CREATE
A PATHWAY FOR NON DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS SUCH AS REMEDIATION
IN MAINTENANCE PROJECTS WE
WANNA MAKE SURE WE GET THE
LANGUAGE EXACTLY RIGHT GIVEN
THE STAKES -- BUT I THINK
WE'RE VERY VERY CLOSE TO DOING
THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON IT
THROUGH THE WEEKEND -- THROUGH
THE FOURTH OF JULY AND EVEN
THROUGH LATE LAST NIGHT SO --
I DO WANT TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN
THE COMMITTEE FOR DOING THAT
WORK UP PRETTY CONSTANTLY
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS
-- WITH ME AND MY STAFF ON
THIS BILL HERE TO TEST POINTS
FOR THE BILL'S JAMES THEY'RE
WALKING FROM THE STATE COUNCIL
BELIEVERS THANK YOU I'M MORE
THAN HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
OR GET INTO DETAIL ON THIS
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
RIVAL THANK YOU SENATOR --
SO WE ARE READY FOR WE HAVE
ONE WITNESS IN SUPPORT -- BY
PHONE MODERATOR KEY PLEASE
OPEN UP THE LINE FOR MISTER
JAMES THREE WACHTER FROM THE
STATE COUNCIL OF LABOUR'S
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE -- MY NAME IS JAMES
THEIR ACTOR AND WITH THE
-- CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL
LABOR'S WE ARE THE PROUD
SPONSOR OF SB THIRTY SEVEN WITH
RESPECT RETIREMENT TO AVOID
REPEATING CENTER CORTESE'S WELL
ARTICULATED POINTS I WILL BE
A PRETTY GRIEF ESKOM INSECT
THANKS EXEMPTION THAT THE
BILL ADDRESSES IS ESSENTIALLY
FOR LACK OF A BETTER TERM
A LOOPHOLE THAT HAS BEEN
EXPLOITED BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
IN RECENT YEARS THESE TYPES OF
EXEMPTIONS ENCOURAGE FAST TRACK
APPROVAL AND ALLOW CITIES TO
AVOID STATE REVIEW DESPITE THE
FACT THAT SUCH EXEMPTIONS ARE
TO APPLY ONLY TO THOSE PROJECTS
REPRESENT NO POSSIBILITY OF
SIGNIFICANT HAZARDS IF YOU HAVE
BEEN SUCCESSFULLY BY PATENT
SEEK REVIEW IF THIS MECHANISM
IN FORTUNATE REALITY THAT
SOME OF THE MOST THREATENING
HAZARDS -- I MEAN TO GIVE A
CONSTRUCTION SITE ARE THOSE
WORKERS CANNOT READILY SEE OR
FEEL SUCH HAZARDS ARE OFTEN THE
RESULT OF CONTAMINATED SOIL AND
GROUNDWATER LEAKY UNDERGROUND
TANKS ON THE MISMANAGEMENT OF
WASTE MATERIALS AMONG OTHER
THINGS SB THIRTY SEVEN SIMPLY
CLARIFIES THAT THE PUBLIC
RESOURCES CODE TO PROVIDE THAT
ALL EXEMPTION INCLUDING YOUR
COMMONSENSE EXEMPTION CANNOT
BE GRANTED TO PROJECTS BUT
OUR NAME ON THE COURT IF YOU
LIST I LIKE TO NOTE THAT WE
ARE SENSITIVE TO THE HOUSING
CRISIS ARTISTS INCREASE THE
SUPPLY OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE BUT WE DO
FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT IN THAT NEW
DEVELOPMENT SHOULD UNDERGO A
COMPREHENSIVE PLANNING PROCESS
THERE STRIVE TO PROTECT THE
ENVIRONMENT AND PUBLIC HEALTH
SB THIRTY SEVEN AT THE PROGRAM
ABOUT TO PUT WHICH EVEN JUST
THAT THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
SUPPORT SO TO THANK YOU SO NEXT
I'LL TAKE ON THE SUPPORT I'M
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT THAT ARE
IN THE HEARING ROOM PLEASE GO
AHEAD THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MATT CRIMMINS HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
NEVADA CONFERENCE OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS HERE TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY QUEST ON BEHALF
OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU THE NEXT ALL
MOVE WE HAVE ONE WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION I'M JOHN KENNEDY
FROM THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
MODERATOR KEY PLEASE OPEN UP
THE LINE FOR MISTER KENNEDY
CHINA'S OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU JOHN KENNEDY AGAIN
WITH RC RC I'M HERE TODAY
TO OPPOSE SB THIRTY SEVEN
BECAUSE IT'S OVERLY BROAD
SUBSTANTIALLY EXPAND SEQUEL TO
WHAT ARE CURRENTLY CONSIDERED
PROJECTS UNDER THE LAW AND
WILL UNNECESSARILY INCREASE
COSTS AND DELAY APPROVAL FOR
MANY TYPES OF MINOR PROJECTS
TO POTENTIALLY THOUSANDS OF
STATE AND LOCAL FACILITIES SB
THIRTY SEVEN PROHIBITS IT WAS
COMMONSENSE EXEMPTION FOR FOR
PROJECTS UNDERTAKEN ON ANY
OF THE COURT TO THE WEST SIDE
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN CERTIFIED
AS REMEDIATED BY DTS SCENE OR
REGIONAL WATER BOARD THOUSANDS
OF STATE LOCAL FACILITIES
ARE ON THE COURT TO DO LIST
INCLUDING LOCAL AIRPORTS FIRE
STATIONS POLICE DEPARTMENTS
CORPORATION YARD AND MANY C.
H.
P.
CALTRANS HELLFIRE AND STATE
PARKS FACILITIES ABOUT FORTY
THOUSAND OF THE COURT TO DO
LIST SITES THAT INVOLVED IS
LEAKING UNDERGROUND STORAGE
TANKS HAVE BEEN CLEANED UP MANY
OF THOSE CLEAN UP ACTIONS WERE
OVERSEEING THEM CLOSE BY LOCAL
AGENCIES IN ACCORDANCE WITH
STATE CLOSER STANDARDS HOWEVER
SB THIRTY SEVEN IS NARROWLY
WRITTEN IN A WAY THAT PROJECTS
AT THOSE SITES OVERSEEN BY
LOCAL AGENCY WILL STILL NOT
BE ABLE TO USE IT BECAUSE
COMMONSENSE OR CATEGORICAL
EXEMPTIONS AT CLEAN UP SITES
THE SEQUEL THE COMMONSENSE
EXEMPTION THAT SB THIRTY SEVEN
RESTRICTS CAN ONLY BE USED
WORDS CLEAR PROJECT WON'T
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT EFFECT ON
THE ENVIRONMENT THE PROJECT
SIMPLY ISN'T SUBJECT TO SEQUIN
LOTS OF MAY HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT ON THE ENVIRONMENT SO
THESE TYPES OF PROJECTS FOR
WHICH THE COMMONSENSE EXEMPTION
ARE TYPICALLY USED IN WOULD
BE IMPACTED BY S.
B.
SB THIRTY SEVEN INCLUDE
RENEWAL OF AN EXISTING LEASE
REPLACEMENT OF AN EXISTING
ROOF INSTALLATION SECURITY
PARTNER FENCING MAINTENANCE
REPLACEMENT OF EXISTING
STRUCTURES NEAR OR INTERIOR
ALTERATIONS AND EVEN PAVEMENT
AND PARKING LOT REPAIRS SB
THIRTY SEVEN REQUIRES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO COMPLY WITH
SEAT PERFORMING INITIAL STUDY
PROVIDE NOTICES AND ISSUED A
NEGATIVE DECLARATION PERCENT
FULLY REPAIRING OR REPLACING
THE ROOF AT A LOCAL FIRE
STATION OR REPAIRING SECURITY
FENCING AT MANY MUNICIPAL
AIRPORTS WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S COMMITMENT TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES IN THE NEXT FEW
WEEKS AND TRULY HOPE WE CAN
REACH AN AGREEMENT TO RESOLVE
OUR CONCERNS AND AVOID THESE
ISSUES UNFORTUNATELY WILL
NOT CONTINUE TO -- OPPOSE
SB THIRTY SEVEN UNTIL IT IS
AMENDED THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL
MOVE TO A WILL OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION PLEASE JUST
STATE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION
AND POSITION ON THE BILL
THANK YOU COULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE CALL AHEAD
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR NUMBERS
NIKITA CROWDED WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
PHOTO LINE EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS NICOLE BORNEMANN
ON BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT
WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD MANAGER MEMBERS
GOOD MORNING PAUL EUROPE WE
HAVE THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO APPRECIATE THAT
THE COMMITTEES WORKED ONCE
IN THE ANALYSIS APPRECIATE
HEARING THE SENATOR HE'S
GOING TO TRY TO ADDRESS
THOSE ITEMS SO WILL KEEP
LOOKING AT THE BILL THANK YOU
NINE FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD MORNING CATHY
SCHAEFER REPRESENTING THE
BRAND OF VALLEY CLIMATE
REALITY PROJECT IN SUPPORT
LOCAL EIGHTY FIVE
YES THIS IS DIANA WATER THE
MORNING MANAGER I ANA WIND
AND SHARE THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY CHAPTER CLIMATE
REALITY IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU
NUMBER ONE THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
CHELSEA TO AND RESPECTFULLY
REGISTERING THE CODE FROM
LATIN AND THAT POSITION ON THE
BILL AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTRE ON BASE
POVERTY AND ENVIRONMENT THANK
YOU THAT'S RIGHT MODERATOR DO
YOU HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL LINE
OPEN WE HEAR SOMEONE TALKING
IN THE BACKGROUND ONLY ONLY
NOISE I SEE IS COMING FROM
YOUR LINE -- HERE WAIT I'M
SORRY THERE IS SOME NOISE
COMING FROM ANOTHER LINE
-- WHEN YOU'RE NOT SPEAKING
PLEASE USE YOUR MUTE BUTTON
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
I'M SORRY RECORDED LINE
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO THIS IS THE LEAST
PONDERED FROM THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION
VOTERS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU WILL GO TO LINE
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS ALEXANDER
NOVICE CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CENTER FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH AND SUPPORT THANK
WE'LL GO TO LINE EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MICHAEL RAT AGAIN
I'LL BE HAPPY SANTA CLARA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION YOU MAKE
IT THANK YOU NOW BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR SENATOR RIGHT
I RESPECT SEVERAL ASPECTS
IN THE INTENT OF THIS BILL
-- SPECIFICALLY THE NEED TO
ENSURE THE PROTECTIONS OF THE
HEALTH OF THE COMMUNITY AND
THOSE WORKING ON POTENTIALLY
HAZARDOUS LAND RECITES HOWEVER
I DO A SHOW CONCERNS WHICH
I HOPE CAN BE ADDRESSED
SPECIFICALLY IN REGARDS TO THE
LOCAL AGENCIES MAKING THE SITES
OF THE EQUITY IS THE LATEST IN
IMPACTED BY THIS MEASURE WERE
LEAKING UNDERGROUND STORAGE
SITES THESE SITES WERE COMMONLY
CLEANED UP AND REPAIRED AND
OVERSEEN BY LOCAL AGENCIES
WHO WERE THEN IN TURN OVER SHE
BY THE REGIONAL WATER BOARDS
ARE THESE SITES WILL NOW NOT
QUALIFY UNDER THE COMMONSENSE
EXEMPTION WITH YOUR BILL
FURTHERMORE THIS ALSO MEANS
THAT MANY MINOR ALTERATIONS
IT IS STATED BY RC RC IN THEIR
TESTIMONY SO I WON'T REPEAT
-- BUT IT'S GOING TO CAUSE
UNDUE AND UNNECESSARY -- TIME
HERE SO I I'M JUST SIMPLY AN
ASSET OR THE THE WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION ON THIS I'M GONNA
LAY OFF THE DAY OUT OF RESPECT
FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS -- AND
HOLD MY VOTE TELL THE FLOOR
THANK YOU THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN -- THANK
YOU SENATOR FOR BRINGING THE
BILL FOR IT I ACTUALLY HAVE
A SIMILAR CONCERN -- BUT IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT IF THERE IS
A WAY TO DRAW A DISTINCTION
BETWEEN PROJECTS THAT WERE
HIGH RISK FOR DISTURBING
SOIL FOR INSTANCE THAT YOU
KNOW POTENTIALLY CONTAMINATED
FROM PROJECTS THAT ARE MINOR
I DIDN'T EVEN IF THE SOIL
WERE CONTAMINATED WOULDN'T
BECAUSE -- YOU KNOW AND --
IN EXASPERATION OF A OF A
EXISTING SITUATION THERE WAS A
WAY TO PARSE THAT OUT IT WOULD
BE HELPFUL AND IN ADDITION
IT'S ALSO MY UNDERSTANDING
ALTHOUGH I'M NOT AN EXPERT
IN THE CORTESE LIST CERTAINLY
THAT ONCE A PROJECT IS ON THAT
LIST IT'S VERY HARD TO GET OFF
EVEN IF IT'S BEEN REMEDIATED
AND SO -- GIVEN THAT SEE WHAT
YOU KNOW IS USE QUITE A BIT
FOR ADDRESSING CONCERNS THAT
HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
UNDERLYING CONCERN THAT THE
SEQUEL REVIEW IS LOOKING AT
YOU KNOW CONCERNS JUST ABOUT
DEVELOPMENT -- ALL KINDS OF
REASONS WHY PEOPLE SOMETIMES
WANT TO DELAY OR STOP THE
PROJECT I HAVE A WORRY THAT
THIS COULD BE USED -- EVEN FOR
SITES WHERE THERE REALLY IS
NOT GOING TO BE AN IMPACT --
THE SITES WHERE THE CHANGES
ARE MINOR SITES WHERE --
-- THE THERE MAY HAVE BEEN
REMEDIATION THAT WAS ADEQUATE
-- AND ESPECIALLY SINCE THE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS DO YOU HAVE
THE ABILITY TO ALSO TO STILL
ASK FOR REMEDIATION ASKED FOR
AN ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW I'M
JUST -- NOT SURE THAT -- --
THEY'RE SORT OF ENOUGH TIMES
WERE LOCALS DON'T ASK FOR THAT
AT TIMES WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE
TO JUSTIFY WHAT COULD HAPPEN
TO THE PROJECTS THAT DON'T
REALLY NEED THIS LEVEL OF
STATISTICAL ANALYSIS YOU KNOW
AT A TIME WHEN WE'RE REALLY
TRYING TO GET MORE HOUSING
BUILT -- AND WHERE PEOPLE
ARE FIGHTING NEW DEVELOPMENTS
YOU KNOW TO THE NOW ALL OVER
THE STATE SO I'M ALSO GONNA
-- LAY OFF THE BILL TODAY
AND I DO HOPE THAT YOU CAN
CONTINUE TO WORK ON IT MAYBE TO
NARROW THE SCOPE OF IT THANKS
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE I DON'T
SEE ANY -- I WANT TO THANK
YOU AS YOU MENTIONED -- IN
IN THE BEGINNING THAT YOU ARE
WORKING WITH OUR COMMITTEE --
ON SOME OF THESE CONCERNS AND
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
YOU UP ON THEM THE CONCERNS ON
MINE OF THE MINOR PROJECTS THE
REMEDIATION AS YOU MENTIONED
DIÇN I HOPE THAT WE CAN GET THE
APPROPRIATE LANGUAGE SOON BUT
THANK YOU I WILL BE SUPPORTING
TODAY TO MOVE THIS FORWARD
-- BUT DEFINITELY WANT US TO
COME TO AN AGREEMENT ON THAT
LANGUAGE SOON THANK YOU MANAGER
YEAH I FEEL MAYOREDLEE I'M
SORRY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
YES -- FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU
-- BUT BELIEVE ME SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT
UP TODAY -- IF NOT ALL OF THEM
HAVE BEEN -- -- WORK THROUGH
AND A FEW OF THEM CONTINUE THE
WORK THROUGH -- BUT LET ME JUST
ADDRESS -- THE CHAIRS CONCERNED
PERSON COMMIT ABSOLUTELY TO --
YOU KNOW IN A MATTER OF DAYS
-- WE'RE NOT WANTED TO COME
BACK IN WEEKS WITH AMENDMENTS
BUT IN DAYS BECAUSE WE FEEL
LIKE WE'RE ABOUT THE SENTENCE
AWAY FROM -- CLEARING UP THE
LAST ISSUE -- THANKS AGAIN
TO COMMITTEE STAFF -- WORKING
HARD AND REALLY PARSING THINGS
OUT WITH US -- THAT SAID --
I JUST WANT TO CLOSE BY BEING
VERY VERY CLEAR AS TO WHAT
IS ACTUALLY HAPPENING OUT
THERE ON THE STREET THAT IS
SO DANGEROUS RIGHT NOW THE
COMMONSENSE EXEMPTION IS NOT
ALTHOUGH IT MAY SOUND LIKE IT
AND AND AND HOW MANY PEOPLE HAD
A CHANCE TO ACTUALLY LOOK AT
THE LANGUAGE BUT IT ISN'T IT'S
A LITTLE BIT OF A A MISLEADING
TITLE BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
MEAN YOU LOOK AT SOMETHING
LIKE A TEMPORARY FENCE WHICH
MONEY TO SAY PARENTHETICALLY
IS ORDINARILY NOT A SEQUEL
PROJECT IN THE FIRST PLACE
SO WE QUESTION SIGNIFICANTLY
HOW SOME FOLKS ARE WORRIED
ABOUT PUTTING A TEMPORARY
FENCE UP WHEN YOU DON'T EVEN
NEED ACROSS THE COUNTER TO
GET A PERMIT LET ALONE A SEEK
REVIEW BUT THAT SAID WITH THE
COMMONSENSE EXEMPTION ACTUALLY
SAYS IS THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NO
POSSIBILITY NO POSSIBILITY WITH
CERTAINTY BASED ON EVIDENCE
THAT THE PROJECT IN THIS CAN
ONLY BE APPLIED TO A PROJECT
THAT IS LISTED IN THE SEQUEL
GOT EYES AS A PROJECT YOU KNOW
NOT TO FIXING THE SHINGLES ON A
ROOF WHICH IS A REPAIR A SINGLE
PROJECT -- IF YOU CAN MEET ALL
THOSE STANDARDS THEN YOU CAN
SAY WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO NEXT
IS EXEMPT FROM ANY TRIGGERING
BY THE CORTES THE LIST OF SEEK
REVIEW NOW THE PROJECT THAT
COMES NEXT MAY STILL TRIGGER
SEQUEL REVIEW BECAUSE IT'S A
STRUCTURE A HOUSE HAS TRAFFIC
IMPACTED HAS WATER RUNOFF
IMPACT WHATEVER BUT FOLKS HAVE
BEEN USING THE WITH CERTAINTY
AND WITH NO POSSIBILITY OF
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT BASED ON
EVIDENCE -- REALLY IN VIOLATION
OF OF IN SOME CASES ALL THREE
OF THOSE TERMS WE WE REVIEWED
AS PART OF ALL THIS WORK THE
APPLICATION AND I DON'T KNOW
THAT EVERYONE -- MAYBE MR
STONE AND A COUPLE OTHERS KNOW
THIS SITE BUT -- THE HUNTERS
POINT SITE IN THE BAY AREA
WHICH PUT IN AN APPLICATION
FOR EXEMPTION APPLICATION FOR
EXEMPTION IN PART BASED ON THE
CORTES THE LIST TO DO WORK ON
THAT SITE REMEDIATION WORK WHAT
WE CALL FACE TO REMEDIATION
WORK WHICH IS A SEQUEL PROJECT
BY DEFINITION THAT INCLUDES
TRENCHING TAKING OIL OFF THE
TOP OF THE BAY OFF THE TOP
OF THE BAY REALLY THIS IS A
KNOWN CONTAMINATED SITES OKAY
AND THEIR ARGUMENT WAS WITH
CERTAINTY WITHOUT GOING ANY
FURTHER WITH CERTAINTY THERE
IS NO POSSIBILITY OF OF --
SIGNIFICAN ENVIRONMENT IMPACT
TO GO FORWARD BASED ON THE
EVIDENCE AND THEY WROTE EIGHT
PAGES THEY GAVE THE EVIDENCE
THEY SAID HERE'S WHAT'S ALL
OUT THERE AND HERE'S WHAT WE
HAVE TO DO BUT THEY WANTED TO
BE ABLE TO DECLARE UNILATERALLY
THAT IT WAS OKAY TO PROCEED
FORWARD WITHOUT EVEN AN INITIAL
STUDY NO ONE WAS ASKING FOR
IT BERMAN WHAT IMPACT REPORT
NOT EVEN AN INITIAL STUDY
COMMONSENSE EXEMPTION SO
THAT'S ONE OF MANY EXAMPLES
WAS LITIGATION PENDING IN THE
STATE AND SO FORTH SO WE KNOW
WE NEED TO -- DEAL WITH THIS
NEED TO DEAL WITH THIS ON THE
CLOSE SITE ISSUE -- THIS BILL
IS THIS BILL IS NOW DESIGNED TO
ALLOW PROJECTS THAT HAVE BEEN
CERTIFICATED AS CLOSED BUT TO
PROCEED FORWARD UNDER ORDINARY
CATEGORICAL EXEMPTIONS RIGHT
PROJECTS THAT WOULD ORDINARILY
BE EXEMPT FROM SEQUEL ANYWAY
CAN PROCEED IRRESPECTIVE OF
THE FACT THAT THE THEY'RE
STILL LISTED ON ON THE SITE
AS ONE OF THE FORTY THOUSAND
THAT'S A CLOSE SITE WHAT WE
NEED TO DO AND I WANT AGAIN
COMMIT TO THE CHAIR IS COME
BACK AND MAKE SURE THAT THE
SUBORDINATES OF DTS SEE LOCALLY
WHO ARE AUTHORIZED TO CLOSE OR
SITES SINCE AND CERTIFY THEM
ARE ENUMERATED IN THE BILL WE
WE THOUGHT IT WAS UNDERSTOOD
IT'S CLEAR THAT PEOPLE WOULD
LIKE US TO YOU KNOW ENUMERATE
-- THE LOCAL AGENCIES THAT ARE
AND ALWAYS HAVE BEEN AUTHORIZED
TO GO IN IT INCLUDES THE SAAB
HAS MISSILES BUT ONCE THEIR
CLOTHES WERE TRYING TO SAY IF
YOU'RE NEXT YOU'RE NEXT STEP OF
YOUR PROJECT WOULD ORDINARILY
GO THROUGH CATEGORICAL -- A
CATEGORY EXEMPTION ANYWAY THANK
WE GOT TO TRUST THE LOCALS ON
THAT -- SO THAT'S WHERE WE'RE
AT -- IN WE RECENTLY SAID WE
ONLY ONCE SINCE WAYS BECAUSE
I'M WE'VE TAKEN THE AMENDMENTS
OF COMMITTEES ALREADY SUGGESTED
WE HAVE -- UP TO A POINT IN THE
CHAIR IN THAT IN THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT KNOWS WHERE THAT IS
WE'RE TRYING TO WE'RE TRYING TO
WORK OUT ONE FINAL SENTENCE I
THINK IT'S ONE FINAL SENTENCE
IN TERMS OF WHERE WE -- WHERE
WE DERIVE -- WHERE WE DERIVE
THE AUTHORITY TO CLOSE I
MEAN TO ALLOW MAINTENANCE IN
REMEDIATION TO GO FORWARD ON
OPEN SITES THAT'S WITH TOO MANY
CONSULTANT IN THE COMMITTEE
STAFF IN YOU'RE ASKING US TO
DO NOW AND -- I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE IS THE POSSIBILITY ON AN
OPEN SITE OF SOMEBODY WANTING
TO DO SOMETHING THAT WOULD
ORDINARILY NOT TRIGGER SEQUEL
AND ON THE OPEN SIDE THEY DON'T
WANT THE LIST TO AUTOMATICALLY
TRIGGER THE TRIGGER SEEK REVIEW
OBVIOUSLY -- THAT LANGUAGE EVEN
IF IT'S ONLY A SENTENCE IS VERY
IMPORTANT SO WE'RE NOT OPENING
UP THE FLOODGATES TO SOMETHING
LIKE I JUST DESCRIBED WITH THE
HUNTERS POINT APPLICATION RIGHT
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THAT IT JUST COMING IN ON AN
OPEN SITE IN DOING THE KIND OF
WORK -- THAT OF THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BROUGHT UP IN THE QUEUE
IN A SO WE'RE VERY CLOSE WE'RE
COMMITTED WE'LL KEEP WORKING
HARD AND I KNOW WE'LL GET THERE
AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE GIVE US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO THAT BECAUSE I
THINK THE WORST THING THAT WE
COULD DO -- IS TO DO NOTHING
GIVEN THE CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT ARE OUT THERE RIGHT NOW
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SENATOR THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
AND BELIEVE WE NEED A MOTION
HELLO
HOLD ON PLEASE
OKAY THERE'S WHAT WOULD
YOU WANT TO BE PASSED OKAY
I BELIEVE SO YOU ARE NOT
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS WE WE HAVE OF WE
AGREE TO WE HAVE SUBMITTED
MEMBERS SO WE HAVE AGREED IN
PRINCIPLE TO AN AMENDMENT THAT
DEALS WITH MAINTENANCE AND
REMEDIATION ON OPEN SITES BUT
WE NEED TO GET THE LANGUAGE
FINALIZED OKAY YES I SAW THE
LANGUAGE LAST NIGHT I'M SURE
SOME LEAVE IN THAT SITUATION
-- YOU KNOW -- YES I I KNOW
YOU HAVE I KNOW YOU HAVE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH US
ON THAT LANGUAGE -- I BELIEVE
THEN THE MOTION IS JUST TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS BOB
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR
NOW RIGHT WITH THE COMMITMENT
THE COMMITMENT TO MAKE -- THE
FINAL AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
WORKING ON WITH REGARD TO
RE MEDIATION A MAINTENANCE
ACTIVITIES ON OPEN SITES OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU JUST A
MINUTE CLARIFY THAT MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS BOB
DO I HAVE TO I ANYBODY WANT
TO MOVE THE BILL K.
OUR MOTION BY -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STONE SECOND BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA I'M
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM TO SB THIRTY SEVENTH BY
SENATOR CORTESE MEMBERS RIVAS
I RIVERSIDE FLORA FLORA I CHAU
CHAU HI FRIEDMAN GARCIA GARCIA
AYE MATHIS MATHIS NOT VOTING
MCCARTY RIGHT SURGERY SARATOGA
SAY OUR TOTAL STONE STONE I
WOULD FIVE ONE K.
FIVE ONE WILL LEAVE
THAT OPEN THANK YOU GIVE
MEASURE MEMBERS APPRECIATE
YOUR ATTENTION THANK YOU
K.
NEXT WILL MOVE TO ITEM NINE
SB FORTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
LEE MON WELCOME THANK YOU
WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU
TEARS MEMBERS SINCE THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED IN SECOND I
DO HAVE A FOLKS WITH ME IN
SUPPORT LAUREN CALLING FROM
THE SIERRA CLUB AND MELISSA
FROM MEADOW FROM SEAL CV TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE GREAT
-- THANK YOU WILL MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
FOR WITH LAUREN COLUMN FROM
THE SIERRA CLUB AND MELISSA
ROMERO FROM THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS
DISTANCE OKAY -- THE MIDDLE
LINE IS OPEN GOOD MORNING OTHER
THE LAUREN COLUMN ON BEHALF
OF SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING A HALF MILLION
MEMBERS AND SUPPORTERS ACROSS
THE STATE YOUR CALL CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT SB FORTY SEVEN BECAUSE
THE BILL WILL HELP INCREASE
FUNDING FOR PLUGGING AND
ABANDONING DESERTED WELL THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS STATE HAS A
MASSIVE AND EXPENSIVE IDLE
DESERTED OILWELL PROBLEM
WITH THE POPULAR DURING THE
KOREAN WAR OIL OPERATORS ARE
STANDING NO RESPONSIBILITY THE
COMMISSION AND THE MEDIA ARE
WELL WHERE IT HAPPENED THE CALL
THE PLUGGING AND ABANDONING
THE DESERTED ORGAN WELL HAPPY
BIRTHDAY AND TAXPAYERS ALMOST
SEVENTY THOUSAND MILES IN
CALIFORNIA OR AT RISK OF BEING
DESERTED BECAUSE THEY'RE EITHER
IDLE OR ECONOMICALLY ONE FIFTY
FIVE HUNDRED WELL THE ALREADY
DESERTED OR HAVE NO VIABLE
OPERATOR HE DOESN'T EIGHTEEN
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL ON
SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY REPORT
ESTIMATED WILL COST ABOUT FIVE
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS TO
REMEDIATE ALL IDLE ECONOMICALLY
MARGINAL AND DESSERT WELL THE
THIRD WORLD A RISK TO PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THE ENVIRONMENT
YOU'RE WELCOME WEEK DEGRADING
AIR QUALITY AND COMPANION
OFFERS A DRINKING WATER
SUPPLIES CREATING OIL P.
AND HARMING NEARBY COMMUNITIES
CLAUDIAN A VANITY PROJECT
WELCOMES NECESSARY TO PROTECT
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
CALIFORNIANS AND AT THE FORTY
SEVEN WILL HELP THE DESERTED
OIL WELL CLEAN UP AS YOU BY
AUTHORITY CALDERON TO SPEND
UP TO FIVE MILLION A YEAR
ON PLUGGING AND ABANDONING
THE THIRD ON A WILD ALLOWING
CONTENT TO USE MORE FUNDS FROM
THE OIL INDUSTRY DEPOSITARY
OIL WELLS ONE CHARITY COSTS ARE
NOT PASSED ALONG PEACOCK AT THE
FORTY SEVEN IT IMPORTANT AND
URGENT BILL TO HELP ADDRESS THE
FATE OF THE THIRD OIL PROBLEM
YOU THANK THEM FOR THE LONG
FOR HER LEADERSHIP AND URGED
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS ABOUT THE
FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU CAL NEXT
TO THE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE -- MY NAME'S MELISSA
ROMERO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND WE'RE
SO PROUD TO SUPPORT SB FORTY
SEVENS WHICH CONTINUES TO STATE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE COMPLEX
CAN'T LEADERSHIP AND HAPPEN
POLICIES THAT INCORPORATE THE
POLLUTER PAYS PRINCIPLE CONTACT
THE PLUGIN ABANDON ORTON WEALTH
OR HIGHLY LIKELY TO BECOME OPEN
WELL BEING BETWEEN FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION AND FIVE BILLION WITH
NEARLY THE LOWER COST ESTIMATE
OF FIVE HUNDRED MILLION BEING
THE CONSERVATIVE CATHOLICS
CALIFORNIA HAVE TO PASS AT
THE FORTY SEVEN AND YOU MORE
TO ENSURE THAT AS WITH THE
TRANSITION TO A CLEAN ENERGY
ECONOMY WE ARE WORKING PACKED
HERE THE OIL INDUSTRY WELL
AND KNOWLEDGEABLE POINTS OUT
IN TWENTY NINETEEN OVER THREE
THOUSAND OF THE THIRTY SEVEN
THOUSAND TWELVE TOTAL I DON'T
THINK WE'RE NOT I DON'T WEALTHY
AND THERE'S A RIVAL BLOWING GAS
COMPANY FINDING EXACTLY BOTH
THE FACTS SHOULD BE A CAUSE
FOR CONCERN FOR THE LEGISLATURE
WITHOUT A THREE FORTY SEVEN PM
NOT LIKE HOW CAN WILL BE ABLE
TO BENEFIT FROM AN ABANDONED
HOUSE I'LL DO THE RESULT WILL
DROP PROJECT ONE MILLION PER
YEAR IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY THREE
AND HUNTING IS DERIVED IN THE
TRUTH THE COST OF AN ABANDONED
JUST ONE HAZARDOUS I DON'T DO
VERY WELL AND IT REALLY CAN
BE POPULATED AREA WHICH COULD
MYSTERIOUS HOLDEN PD RESCUE
PEOPLE LIVING HERE ARE QUITE
LITERALLY ON TOP OF THE SITE
COULD POTENTIALLY ENOUGH THAT
ENTIRE ONE MILLION CAP YOU
TO THE KONSTANTINOV WELLBEING
MUCH HIGHER DEPENDING ON HOW
DEEP THE WELL IS AND HOW CLOSE
IN PROXIMITY TO WELL IF YOU
GET PEOPLE THAT IS WHY IT'S SO
CRITICAL TO THE STATE INCREASE
HAPPEN FUNDING NOW PARKING
AT THE FORTY FIVE AND A THREE
FORTY SEVEN PROTECT COPYRIGHTS
PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT I
WOULD HELP THANK CREEPING
THE ANNUAL AMOUNT AVAILABLE
CALTRAIN TO CREATE POSITIVE I
DON'T THINK THEIR OIL WEALTH
TO FIVE MILLION ANNUALLY ON
GUNS WE URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO SUPPORT THE WEALTHY THANK
SENATOR LAMONT LEADERSHIP ON
THE ISSUE AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
IN COURT SB FORTY FIVE AND THAT
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL MOVE
TO A WE HAVE ONE WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION THE -- POTHOLES
FROM THE CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION MODERATOR
KEY PLEASE ON THE MORNING MADAM
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS STILL PALES REPRESENT
THE CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION BUT
WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE ON THE
UPSET THAT THIS BILL HAS BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY AMENDED FROM ITS
ORIGINAL FORM AND -- HAS BEEN
GREATLY APPROVED HOWEVER WE
DO REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE BILL
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THAT THE POT
OF MONEY THAT IS ESTABLISHED
THIS BILL IS UNNECESSARY
GIVEN WHAT HAS HAPPENED IN
PREVIOUS LAWS -- THAT PASSED
WHICH COMMITTEE THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY NINE PASSES COMEDIAN
BECAME LAW WHICH REQUIRED ALL
OF THE PRODUCERS TO DEVELOP
AN IDOL WELL MANAGEMENT PLAN
TO TRACK AND REMEDIATE THE
PERCENTAGE OF THEIR OWN I THE
WORLD'S ANNUALLY THE BILL ALSO
STIPULATED THAT IN LIEU OF
AN IDOL WELL MANAGEMENT PLAN
COMPANIES CAN OPT TO PAY FEES
INTO THE HAVE HAZARDOUS IDLE
AND DESERTED WELL ABATEMENT
FIVE CURRENTLY WELL COMPANIES
OF DEPOSIT OVER SEVENTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN THIS ACCOUNT
THANK YOU TO OPT IS GROWING AS
NO STATUTORY CAP ON HOW MUCH
CAN BE DEPOSITED THERE'S ALSO
NO CAP ON HOW MUCH THE STATE
CAN SPEND THEM AND WALKED TO
REMEDIATE OFTEN WELL HEADWATERS
A POWERFUL TOOL EXISTENCE IS
CLOSER TO ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM
OF WORK WITH WELLS IN ADDITION
TO THAT THE SAME AUTHORIZED
PASSED LEGISLATION AS RECENTLY
AS TWO YEARS AGO TO INCREASE
FINANCIAL ASSURANCES PROVIDED
BY WILL PRODUCES TO THE STATE
THE MAXIMUM THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A COMPANY TO SIT IN
RESERVE FOR THE BIG APPLICATION
SO BETWEEN THE HEADWATER COUNT
AND BETWEEN PASSED BILLS BY
THE SAME AUTHOR THAT INCREASE
FINANCIAL ASSURANCES WE BELIEVE
THAT THERE ARE TOOLS TO MANAGE
ABANDONED AND ORPHANED WELLS
CURRENTLY I DO NOT BELIEVE
THAT AN ADDITIONAL FIND FIND
A FIVE MILLION APPLES TIME IF
NECESSARY I WOULD LIKE TO NOTE
THAT TO PASS A BUDGET YEARS
SO I HAVE ALWAYS APPROVED AND
SUPPORTED ADDITIONAL INCREASES
IN DOLLAR PONDS AT SKEWS ME
PAL JIM FINDS THESE ARE NOT
ORDINARY MEDIATION MEDIATION
ALL OF WELLS THEREFORE WE
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THIS
BILL IS NECESSARY THANK YOU
THANKS NEXT WE'LL MOVE TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION OF I DON'T SEE
ANY IN THE HEARING ROOM OR THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY LOCATIONS WILL
OPEN UP THE LINES TWO WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
PLEASE JUST STATE YOUR NAME
THINKING FILIATION IMPOSITION
THANK YOU IF YOU'D LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME WE'LL GO TO
LINE SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD THANKS MANAGER NUMBERS
INTO KARATE PHOTOGRAPHERS
ON COUNCIL CLAIMS PROCESS
BEFORE THE FACT THANK YOU
WE'LL GO TO LINE SIXTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
NINE SIXTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN
SORRY ABOUT THAT -- BUT I'M
SURE THIS IS MARK FENSTER MAKER
ON BEHALF OF -- JUSTICE WE ARE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH
LINE NINETY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS ELIZABETH
ESPINOSA ON BEHALF OF THE
VENTURA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS ALSO IN SUPPORT
OF SB FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU
NINE FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD JANET CLARK FOR THREE
FIFTY TALK ON VALLEY IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
NINE EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE EIGHTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN
NO RESPONSE WILL CONTINUE
LINE FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
GABRIELLE DID -- CALLING
IN ON BEHALF OF THREE FIFTY
SOME GROUPS IN SUPPORT
IT'S DAHLE THANK YOU
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
THIS IS CATHERINE RONIN I'M
A MEMBER OF THREE FIFTY AND
I SUPPORT SB FORTY SEVEN
THANK YOU LINE EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD YEAH
GOOD MORNING THIS IS HELEN
CONLEY REPRESENTING C.
FROG CLIMATE FIRST REPLACING
OIL AND GAS VENTURA
COUNTY WE ARE STRONGLY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
WHAT A LINE FORTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD THIS IS LIZ COMPOST
FROM THE WEST SIDE COMMUNITY
COUNCIL MANOS UNIDAS AND THE
WEST BY CLEAN AIR COALITION IN
VENTURA CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND DEMAND
THE EXPANSION OF FOSSIL FUELS
IN VENTURA BE ENDED THANK YOU
LINE NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD
YES WILL CLEAR ON BEHALF
OF FIFTY SACRAMENTO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
RECORDED LINE SIXTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
THE STANDARD TECH CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES PLEASE GO AHEAD
GET YOUR LINE IS OPEN GEN THE
CHECK ON BEHALF OF THREE FIFTY
SOUTH LAND LEGISLATIVE ALLIANCE
FOUNDER THREE FIFTY VENTURA
COUNTY CARLA HOLD ON THE THREE
FIFTY SOUTH SOUTH BAY L.
A.
ALL IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF POSSIBLY DANGEROUS
SUPPORT AND WELL
COOPER LINE NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD THE BILL MURPHY
ON BEHALF OF THE THOUSAND
MEMBERS OF ELDERS CLIMATE
ACTION IS NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
CHAPTERS IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU WILL GO TO LINE
ONE OH ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
-- HI ALL OF THE ONE AND
I CAN'T BE PROTECTED CAL
THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
PLEASE CONTINUE AFTER THANK
YOU THIS IS THE AGUIAR-CURRY
ON BEHALF OF THE WESTERN
STATES PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION
WE ARE IMPOSSIBLE NOT THAT
OKAY WAS THAT THE
LAST WITNESS MODERATOR
YES OKAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE
-- ASSEMBLY MEMBER C.
R.
TWO THANK YOU SO I THINK WE
CAN ALL AGREE THAT WE NEED
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT THESE
WELLS AND -- THE CURRENT CAP
IS THREE MILLION DOLLARS IF I'M
NOT MISTAKEN IS THAT CORRECT
THAT'S CORRECT ALL RIGHT HAVE
THEY USE THE THREE MILLION
DOLLARS YET TO DO ANY OF THIS
WORK SO THERE IS STATUTORY
LAW THAT THEY CANNOT GO OVER
THREE MILLION THEY'VE CERTAINLY
USED UNDER THREE MILLION BUT
THEY CANNOT GO ONE DOLLAR OVER
THREE MILLION SO THAT IS WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO INCREASE TO FIVE
MILLION RIGHT BUT THEY HAVEN'T
EVEN GOT TO THE THREE MILLION
YET THEY'VE STILL AT THEY THEY
TH ANNUAL PRO THEY DO GET TO
A CERTAIN AMOUNT EACH YEAR IT
HAS TO BE UNDER AND THE WAY
THAT IT WORKS IT'S BASED ON
THE PROJECT SO THEY'RE LOOKING
AT PROJECTS THAT ARE UNDER
THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN ORDER
TO DO THEM SAID IF APPROVED
THE YOU KNOW THERE'S A LIST
OF DIFFERENT PROJECTS SO THE
IDEA IS TO GET TO AS MANY AND
CERTAINLY THERE'S PROJECTS THAT
RANGE BETWEEN SEVERAL HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND YOU KNOW
THREE MILLION SO YES EVERY
YEAR THEY USE THE MONEY DO THEY
USE IT UP TO THREE MILLION NO
BECAUSE THEY CANNOT START A
SECOND PROJECT WITHOUT THAT SO
IT'S IT'S IT'S GONNA BE A GIVEN
THAT THEY WILL NEVER ACTUALLY
GET TO THE EXACT AMOUNT GIVEN
THE STATUTORY OKAY AND THEN
THEY COLLECT THIS FROM THE
PRODUCERS INDUSTRY CORRECT
INDUSTRY SO THEY PAY AND AND
THEY RECOVER THAT BY RAISING
PRICES ON THE BARREL OF OIL
THE INDUSTRY HAS HAD OUR WE'RE
GONNA CLOSE TO FIVE DOLLARS
A GALLON FOR GAS YEAH I WOULD
NOT NECESSARILY EQUATE THAT
WITH THAT I THINK THAT THE
EVIDENCE IS NOT NECESSARILY
THERE TO MAKE A CLAIM THAT IT'S
BECAUSE OF MY HE IT THAT IT'S
BECAUSE OF THIS FEET TO GET
TO FIVE DOLLARS GAS I THINK
THERE'S DIFFERENT ELEMENTS
INCLUDING INTERNATIONAL
ELEMENTS AS WELL AND HAPPY
TO HAVE THAT CONVERSATION
RIGHT THANK YOU MMHM
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONTINUED WORK ON THIS
ISSUE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS
SECONDED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GARCIA THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ONE
ITEM NINE SB FORTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR LIMóN MEMBERS
RIVAS HI RIVERSIDE FLORIDA
CHAU CHOW I FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN
AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
MATHIS MATHIS NO MCCARTY RIGHT
SEARCHES WELL TWO G.
I.'S AIRTEL NO THEY ARE
DON'T KNOW STONE STONE
I WOULD SIX TWO K.
SIX TWO WILL LEAVE THAT
OPEN THANK YOU BAKER
MATCH CHEN MEMBERS SENATOR
OKAY SO WE WILL MOVE
TO ITEM TEN SB EIGHTEEN
BY SENATOR SKINNER
OKAY ALL
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ALL TAKE THAT IS A GOOD SIGN
-- AND THE PURPOSE OF THIS
BILL IS TO HELP -- ADVANCE
SCREEN HARD TO GIN HYDROGEN
BY REQUIRING OUR AIR RESOURCES
BOARD AND OTHER STATE
AGENCIES TO START PLANNING
SO CALIFORNIA CAN TAKE FULL
ADVANTAGE OF IT AND WITH THAT
LET ME TURN TO MY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT JANICE LYNN FROM
THE GREEN HYDROGEN COALITION
AND NIKITA KHARADI FROM IN
OUR DC THANK YOU MODERATOR
KEY PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
JANICE LYNN FROM THE GREEN
HYDROGEN COALITION AND THE
KEY TO KARATE FROM THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL
THANK YOU -- CAN YOU HEAR
ME OK YES PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND I'D LIKE TO
THANK CHAIR RETESTING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY MY NAME IS JANICE
LYNN AND I'M THE FOUNDER AND
PRESIDENT OF THE GREEN HYDROGEN
COALITION OR A FIVE OH ONE C.
THREE NONPROFIT HIS MISSION
IS TO ADVANCE GREEN HYDROGEN
PRODUCTION AND USE AT SCALE
TO ACCELERATE MULTI SECTORAL
DECARBONISATION GREEN HYDROGEN
IS A GAME CHANGER IN OUR FIGHT
AGAINST CLIMATE CHANGE BECAUSE
IT'LL ENABLE CARBONIZATION OF
HARD TO OF THE CHAPTERS THAT
ARE NOT EASILY ELECTRIFIED
MAINTAIN GOOD PAYING JOBS
AND POSITION CALIFORNIA WELL
FOR THE EMERGING GLOBAL GREEN
HYDROGEN EXPORT MARKET I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
PERCENTAGE ONLY EIGHTEEN AS IT
IS ESSENTIAL TO ESTABLISHING
AN APPROPRIATE VISION AND
FOUNDATIONAL LEGAL AND
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK FOR GREEN
HYDROGEN THIS IS IMPORTANT
TO ENSURE BANKABILITY AND
INSTABILITY FOR THE TRILLIONS
AND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT
NEED TO BE INVESTED IT IS
LEGAL AND REGULATORY FRAMEWORK
INCLUDES ESTABLISHING AN
APPROPRIATE DEFINITION FOR
GREEN HYDROGEN BUT DOES NOT
EXCLUDE TECHNOLOGIES AND
HAS CLAIMED INTEGRITY THEIR
TREMENDOUS BENEFITS OF GREEN
HYDROGEN FOR CALIFORNIA
NAMELY FIRST I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THREE THINGS IT'S A
GREAT WAY TO ELECTRIFY INDY
CAR TONIGHT OUR FUEL SUPPLY
WE CAN CONVERT ARE ABUNDANT
RENEWABLE RESOURCES INTO A
FLEXIBLE ZERO CARBON FUEL THAT
CAN DISPLACING MANY FOSSIL
FUEL APPLICATIONS INCREASING
RELIABILITY AND RESILIENCY
WE SECONDLY WE CLEAN HYDROGEN
WE CAN REPURPOSE VALUABLE
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
AFFORDABLE ENERGY TRANSITION
AS AN EXAMPLE OF LOS ANGELES
DEPARTMENT OF WATER AND POWER
IS IN THE PROCESS OF CONVERTING
ITS LAST REMAINING COAL PLANT
LOCATED IN CENTRAL UTAH TWO
EIGHT ONE HUNDRED PERCENT
HYDROGEN FUELED COMBINED CYCLE
GAS TURBINE AND THE LAST REASON
MEAN THERE ARE MANY OTHER
BENEFITS BUT THE THIRD I WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT TODAY'S THAT GREEN
HYDROGEN IS THE TREMENDOUS
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND JOB
CREATING EXPORT OPPORTUNITY
FOR CALIFORNIA MANY COUNTRIES
AROUND THE WORLD ARE VYING
TO BECOME LEADING GREEN
HYDROGEN PRODUCERS INCLUDING
AUSTRALIA CHILE SPAIN SAUDI
ARABIA AND CALIFORNIA SHOULD
BE ONE OF THEM WITHOUT SB
EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA IS AT RISK
OF FALLING BEHIND GLOBALLY
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I
DON'T WANNA SPEAKING TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIA'S CONTINUED GLOBAL
LEADERSHIP AND THE CLEAN
ENERGY TRANSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
I DO NOT COMMUTER
LINE CONNECTED
OKAY THEN WE WILL MOVE ON --
TO ADDITION I DON'T HAVE ANY
OF WITNESSES REGISTERED IN
OPPOSITION SO WE'LL MOVE ON
TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION I DON'T
SEE ANY IN THE HEARING ROOM OR
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY LOCATION
SO WE WILL OPEN UP THE LINES
FOR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
THANK YOU IF YOU'D LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME LINE
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
-- GOOD MORNING IS THE WALL
COMING UP THE SENATE RETURNS
CATION GARMENTS THE ONLY TWO
CHARACTERS TUITION COMMISSION
AND THE ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA
TRANSIT DISTRICT ALL IN
SUPPORT OF SPEAKING THANK YOU
-- QUOTE ONLINE ONE OH EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD HI THIS IS
HARISH ROSENBLOOM OF THE
LOS ANGELES BUSINESS COUNCIL
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHTEEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE OH SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD HI THIS IS
DANIEL CHANDLER WITH THREE
FIFTY HUMBOLDT -- WE'RE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AS
AMENDED TO ACTUALLY DEFINE
GREEN HYDROGEN THANK YOU
LINE ONE HAND PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE CANADIAN CARE KARATE BUT
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL AND ACTUALLY HAVING
ISSUES ON THE MAIN WHAT LOOK
BUT THE PLAN FOR COPING TO
REGISTER MY COMMENTS ON THE
PUBLIC OKAY PLEASE GO AHEAD
GREAT THANKS SO MUCH I'M AND
IF YOU PLEASED TO SUPPORT AT
THE EIGHTEEN TODAY WE'D LIKE
TO THANK SENATOR SKINNER HER
STAFF AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
FOR THEIR CONTINUED ENGAGEMENT
ON THE BILL THIS PROCESS HAPPEN
TRULY COLLABORATIVE AND WE
REALLY APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
HARD WORK TO GET TO THIS POINT
THE REASON AMENDMENT PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE TO THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION AND THE
ENERGY COMMISSION THAT'S NEEDED
TO DEVELOP DEFINITIONS FOR
DIFFERENT HYDROPONICALLY IN
THEIR APPLICATION WE SUPPORT
THE HOLISTIC APPROACH IN
ASSESSING THE TECHNOLOGICAL
PROPERTIES THE STOCK PRICE OF
ENERGY AND OTHER INPUTS USED
TO CREATE THE HYDROGEN AND
BOTH THE ENVIRONMENTAL AND
PUBLIC HEALTH IMPACT OF THESE
PROPERTIES BEFORE IDENTIFYING
DIFFERENT TYPES THAT YOU THE
PACKAGE AND OUR PERSPECTIVE
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE DON'T
NARROWLY FOCUSED ON GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS TO THE EXCLUSION
OF OTHER AND TALK EXCITED TO
SEE PROGRESS ON HYDROGEN IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE VARIOUS
STATE AGENCIES AND THEY NEED
HELP TO GET THE DEFINITIONS
AND POLICY IS ALIGNED WITH
OUR CLIMATE AND PUBLIC HEALTH
PRIORITIES THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPLY TO THE
AND WE URGE YOUR IDOL AND SPT
WHAT A LINE SIXTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD THANK YOU TO MEMBERS
YOUR HONOR IF YOU DON'T ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HYDROGEN COALITION ON THE PART
NINE FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS JIM CROMARTY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE LEAGUE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU LINE
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD MORNING MR BLAIR BARROWS
ON BEHALF OF THE INDEPENDENT
ENERGY PRODUCERS ASSOCIATION
AND THE COURT THANK YOU
ONE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD HELLO THIS IS RYAN
MCCARTY WITH THE WHITE IN THE
GROUP AND ON BEHALF OF AQUA
HIJACKS MAGNUM DEVELOPMENT AND
MITSUBISHI POWER AMERICANS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF S.
B.
EIGHTEEN THANK YOU
FINE THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
BREANNA PANETTA ON BEHALF OF
CAL START IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NINE FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD THIS IS JANET TALKS
SEARCH AGENCY SILICON VALLEY
WE OUR POSITION IS THE PORK
IF I MENDED AND ALIGNMENT
WHAT THREE FIFTY HUMBOLDT
AND THANK YOU TO SENATOR
SKINNER FOR ALL HER HARD
WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE
LINE SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
MORNING ERIN RODRIGUEZ TO THE
UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
LINE EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD THE MORNING CARE THE
COMMONWEALTH AND FOR THE
CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN BUSINESS
COUNCIL ON YOUR IN SUPPORT
OF THAT STUFF THANK YOU
ONE MOMENT
LINE SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD THANK YOU MODERATOR GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL ALSO SCORED
NINE NINE YEAH I'M TIELINE NATE
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
THE BILL MURPHY ON BEHALF OF
ELDERS CLIMATE ACTIONS NOR
CAL SO CAL CHAPTERS SUPPORT
IMPLEMENTED WERE IN ALIGNMENT
WITH THREE FIFTY HUMBLE THREE
FIFTY SILICON VALLEY TO MORE
TIGHTLY DEFINED GREEN HYDROGEN
THANK YOU LINE ONE THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS POLICY I'M
ON BEHALF OF THE INTERNATIONAL
BROTHERHOOD OF BOILERMAKERS
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU THERE ARE NO OTHER
LINES IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
YOU MAY CONTINUE THANK YOU
NEXT WILL MOVE TO QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS WILL
START WITH THIS FAMILY MEMBER
MATHIS THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
-- THE CENTERS CAN I I LOVE
WHAT YOU'RE DOING HERE -- YOU
KNOW AS WE TRY TO APPROACH OUR
OUR CLIMATE GOALS OR CARBON
GOALS IS IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
DON'T LOCK OURSELVES IN A BOXES
OF STRICTLY ELECTRIFICATION
IN HYDROGEN TECHNOLOGY A AND
RESEARCHING IT AND KNOWING IT
AND BEING A GRADUATE OF THE
DEAL YOU SCHOOL THIS IS THE
BEST STEP FOR US TO GO THIS IS
THE FUEL THAT CAN HANDLE HEAVY
EQUIPMENT WE'VE JUST BROKEN
LANDS MILE TRAVELED RECORDS
WITH HYDROGEN FUELS AND WE NEED
TO GET THE STATE IN LINE WITH
EVERYBODY ELSE AS WAS MENTIONED
YOU KNOW WE WE KNOW FRANCE IN
EUROPE AND AUSTRALIA AND EVEN
THE ASIAN MARKETS ARE SWITCHING
TO THIS THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
ELECTRIFICATION BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THAT DOESN'T WORK THEY'RE
SWITCHING TO HYDROGEN MODELS
BECAUSE THEY KNOW YOU CAN SWAP
OUT A TANK OF THIS RARE TAKE
A HYDROGEN YOU GET THE SYSTEM
UP AND RUNNING THE UNDERSTAND
THAT LOGISTICALLY FREIGHT
AND GOODS MOVEMENT MOVES WITH
FEELS IN THAT THESE THINGS ARE
ALREADY STRATEGICALLY PLACED
IN IT MAKES SENSE TO MOVE TO
A NEW CLEANER FUEL WHICH IS
HYDROGEN -- I'D LOVE TO BE A
CO AUTHOR ON THIS WITH YOU I
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
WITH YOU YESTERDAY -- AND
I JUST WANT TO KNOW THIS IS
A FRIEND A HYDROGEN IN THIS
IS THE DIRECTION WE NEED
TO MOVE THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU ARE CHAIR --
APPRECIATE -- THE COMMENTS
FROM THE COLLINS THE -- MY
PHYSICIAN ON THIS IS -- I THINK
WE ARE CALIFORNIA'S WEISS TO
BE AS TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL AND
FUEL NEUTRAL AS POSSIBLE IN AS
LONG AS THOSE TECHNOLOGIES AND
FUELS GET US TO OUR CLIMATE
PROTECTION GOALS AND SO I AM
NOT ANTI ANY OF THAT PARTICULAR
TECHNOLOGIES -- FUELS THAT
WERE PERSON CURRENTLY PURSUING
SUCH AS ELECTRIFICATION THOUGH
AS IS POINTED OUT IN THE BILL
I CLEARLY SEE AS LONG AS WE
CAN DO IT IN A WAY THAT DOES
A CHEAPER CLIMATE PROTECTION
GOALS A ROLE FOR HYDROGEN AND
SO THAT IS WHY I'M CARRYING
THE BILL AND -- -- WELL I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR
US TO BE PLANNING FOR IT AND
WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS SECOND
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM TEN SB
EIGHTEEN BY SENATOR SKINNER
MEMBERS RIVAS HI THIS SIZE
FLORA CHAU CHAU I FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA GARCIA
HI MATHIS MATHIS AYE MCCARTY
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I SAY
ARE CHAU HI SIR TWO EYES STONE
STONE I WOULD EIGHT ZERO EIGHT
ZERO THAT FILLS OUT BUT WE'LL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS TO ADD ON THANK YOU
SENATOR THANKS SO MUCH NEXT
WE'LL MOVE TO ITEM EIGHT SB
THREE SEVENTY TWO BY SENATOR
LEYVA MOVED THE BILL WELL
THAT'S A NICE WELCOME GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
IT'S BEEN ONE OF THOSE ACTUALLY
I LOVE THESE DAYS WHEN IT'S
CRAZY BUSY GOES BY QUICKLY I'D
LIKE TO THINK A MADAM CHAIR IN
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
HELP AND HARD WORK ON THIS
BILL IS MUCH APPRECIATED I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AND COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ON
PAGE FIVE OF THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS SB THREE SEVENTY
TWO ESTABLISHES THE MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTY ZERO EMISSION
FLEET VEHICLE FLEET PURCHASING
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM YES SAY THAT
FIVE TIMES FAST IN CONSULTATION
WITH STAKEHOLDERS DESIGN NEW
FINANCING TOOLS TO HELP OWNERS
OF MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES PURCHASE CLEANER ZERO
EMISSION ALTERNATIVES AS MANY
OF YOU ARE AWARE MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS AND BUSES ARE
A MAJOR SOURCE OF AIR POLLUTION
IN CALIFORNIA CONTRIBUTING
TO POOR AIR QUALITY AND
NEGATIVE RESPIRATORY HEALTH
OUTCOMES THESE -- MISSIONS
PERFECT HEALTH OF CALIFORNIANS
ESPECIALLY THOSE IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED POPULATIONS REPLACING
THESE VEHICLES WITH ZERO
EMISSION ALTERNATIVES IS
NEEDED TO REDUCE THE HARMFUL
AIR POLLUTION THAT NEGATIVELY
IMPACTS THESE COMMUNITIES
IN ORDER TO MEET THE DIVERSE
FINANCIAL NEEDS OF CURRENT
AND FUTURE FLEET OWNERS IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT WE ADD MORE
TOOLS TO THE STATE'S TOOLBOX
THE INTENT OF THIS BILL IS
TO GET THE THE STATE TO THINK
CREATIVELY ABOUT HOW WE CAN
BEST LEVERAGE STATE FUNDS
BRING IN PRIVATE CAPITAL AND
INSTANCES WHERE THAT MAKES
SENSE AND PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO MAXIMIZE THE
ABILITY FOR FLEETS OF ALL SIZES
TO TRANSITION TO ZERO EMISSION
OPTIONS SB THREE SEVENTY
TWO WILL ALSO CREATE A ONE
STOP SHOP WEBSITE TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ABOUT ALL OF THE
POTENTIAL FINANCING GRANT
OPTIONS AND OTHER TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THAT IS AVAILABLE
TO HELP OBTAIN FINANCING FOR
THESE VEHICLES MEMBERS WE
KNOW THAT TRANSITION TO ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES IS A KEY
COMPONENT TO ENSURING BETTER
HEALTH AND ECONOMIC BENEFITS
FOR CALIFORNIANS AS WELL AS
HAVING A ROBUST AND CREATIVE
FINANCING TOOLS THAT WILL HELP
TO ACCELERATE OUR ABILITY AND
GET CLEANER AND GREENER TRUCKS
ON THE ROAD BEFORE I CAME TO
THE SENATE I HAVE NEVER HEARD
OF AN UNFUNDED MANDATE SO THIS
BILL IS GOING TO TRY AND HELP
OUR SMALL AND MEDIUM FLEETS TO
FIND THE FINANCING SO WE DON'T
JUST SETTLE THEM WITH THIS
REQUEST ON THE PHONE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT FOR MICHAEL KOPEN
WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
FUND AND KEVIN HAMILTON WITH
THE CENTRAL CALIFORNIA AS A
COLLABORATIVE MEMBERS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE THANK YOU
MODERATOR CAME PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
YES OUR LINES ARE OPEN YES
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MICHAEL
HOLDEN AND GOOD MORNING JERRY
THIS NUMBER THAT THE COMMITTEE
-- AS I SAID MY NAME IS MICHAEL
CALLING WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND AND WE ARE THE
SPONSORS OF SENATE BILL THREE
SEVEN TWO MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLE MARKET WHICH
INCLUDES EVERYTHING FROM SEMI
TRUCKS DELIVERY VANS TO CITY
BUSES AND GARBAGE TRUCKS IS
TRANSITIONING TO ZERO EMISSIONS
THIS TRANSITION WILL HAVE AN
OUTSIZED IMPACT OUR STATE'S
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
ESPECIALLY WHEN CONSIDERING
LOCAL AIR POLLUTION HE SAYS
HE DID HELP IMPROVEMENTS
CALIFORNIA CANNOT TRANSFORM
THIS MARKET JUST USING PUBLIC
FUNDS IT IS TIME TO BRING IN
PRIVATE CAPITAL TO GENERATE
LEVERAGE IN ORDER TO MAKE THIS
TRANSITION AS EXPEDIENT AND
EQUITABLE AS POSSIBLE SENATE
BILL THREE SEVEN TWO EIGHT
SHE'S THREE KEY PRINCIPLES ARE
SAID TO PLEASE MONIES WHERE IT
IS NEEDED MOST BY CONCENTRATING
SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT OF THE
FUNDS TYPICALLY TOWARD VOCAL
POPULATION I'D LIKE TO THANK
OUR ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
PARTNERS ARE COLLABORATING
WITH US ON THIS DEFINITION
SECOND ENABLED IN PRIVATE
INVESTMENT AND FINANCING
OPTIONS FOR ALL THREE SIDES
BY DIRECTING THAT CALIFORNIA
POLLUTION CONTROL FINANCING
AUTHORITY TO UTILITARIAN
SIFTING RELATIONSHIPS WITH
PRIVATE FINANCING INSTITUTIONS
IN WITH THE TRUCKING INDUSTRY
EDS HE IS THE -- THE CRITICAL
IMPLEMENTING PARTNER IT'S
HARD TO THE FULL SET OF
RELEVANT BARRIERS TO THE FLEET
TRANSACTION HAVING THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD IS THE MINISTRY
NEEDS AND BEING ABLE TO SKINNER
AGENCY COORDINATING INTERAGENCY
COORDINATION INCLUDING THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A ONE STOP
SHOP DONE RIGHT SENATE BILL
THREE SEVEN TWO WILL DELIVER
CRITICAL SOCIETAL AND ECONOMIC
BENEFITS INCLUDING IMPROVED
PUBLIC HEALTH REDUCE CLIMATE
POLLUTION LOWER LIFE CYCLE
COSTS OF THE OPERATION VEHICLES
I'D LIKE TO THANK SENATOR
LEYVA AND HER STAFF WITH A
CLEARER VIEW BEIJING SEPT NINE
KIRCHER I THOUGHT THANK YOU
NEXT WEEK NOT TO THE OTHER
WITNESS CONNECTED THEY'RE NOT
CONNECTED OKAY WE HAVE WE WE
HAD KEVIN HAMILTON FROM THE
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA ASTHMA
COLLABORATIVE BUT HE IS NOT
CONNECTED SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION I SEE NOT IN
THE HEARING ROOM NONE AT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY LOCATION SO
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AND RECORDED LINE
ONE TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
NINE ONE TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
OKAY WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD MORNING I'M SURE
MANY MEMBERS JAVA CLASS
ON BEHALF OF THE PORT OF
SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE SEVENTY TWO THANK YOU
FINE FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
THE DOWN APPROXIMATELY FIFTY
THOUSAND VALLEY IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
LINE SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
NINE SIXTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN
FOR THE NEXT LINE A MOMENT
NINE ONE FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD PATRICK WELL THROUGH
THE CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITY DISSERTATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU LINE THIRTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
BREANNA CANNOT ON BEHALF
OF CHARACTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU LINE SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
WHEN YOU MANAGE ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU LINE SIXTY ONE
THREE FOUR HEN SH GOOD
MORNING THIS IS A LIFE PARTNER
QUIT THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE
OF CONSERVATION VOTERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
LINE SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD MORNING AARON RODRIGUEZ
FOR THE UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS THE COURT THANK YOU
LINE ONE SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD HI THIS IS MERRY AND FOR
A ON BEHALF OF THREE FIFTY BAY
AREA ACTION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU LINE
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
ON BEHALF OF THREE FIFTY
SACRAMENTO SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU LINE ONE OH SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD -- DANIEL
CHANDLER THREE FIFTY
HUMBOLDT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU LINE NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD PHIL MURPHY
ON BEHALF OF ELDERS CLIMATE
ACTIONS NOR CAL CHAPTER AND
SOCAL CHAPTER IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU ONLINE SIXTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD DATES ARE
A GOOD MORNING I'M WITH THE
VENTURA THREE FIFTY VENTURA
COUNTY CLIMBED UP INTO A
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU LINE ONE EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU
TURN MEMBERS NIKITA KARATE
BUT AND ARE YOU SEE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU LINE ONE NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD MORNING
CAMMY PAYER WITH NEXT GEN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
LINE SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
NINE SIXTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN
AND THERE ARE NO FURTHER LINES
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION PLEASE
CONTINUE THAT AND CHECK HE
NEXT WILL MOVE TO QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I DON'T SEE ANY WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE SENATOR NUMBERS --
JUST RESPECTFULLY I AM ASKING
SKEWS ME MODERATE LINE SIXTY
SIX DID COME BACK IN WOULD
YOU LIKE TO TAKE THAT I'M SURE
WILL TAKE THAT THANK YOU I'M
SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
ACCORDING TO THE COMPLETION
AND JENNIFER TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY AND CALIFORNIA
HAS TAKEN COALITION AND REPORT
THANK YOU SO WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS
SECONDED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CHAO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ONE
ITEM EIGHT SB THREE SEVENTY
TWO BY SENATOR LEYVA MEMBERS
THREE OF US I REQUEST ALL
FIVE FLORA CHAU FRIEDMAN
GARCIA SEE I MATHIS MATHIS AYE
MCCARTY -- THROUGH G.
WELL TO GI SAY OUR JOB BY SAY
ARE TO AYE STONE WOOD FIVE
THINKING MEMBERS THANK YOU
-- OR K.
WERE WAITING FAR LAST
AUTHORS SENATORS STERN
I BELIEVE HE'S ON HIS WAY
EXACTLY SO MUCH
--
YEAH YEAH OKAY -- OKAY
BECAUSE
-- --
--
YEAH
OKAY
THE YEAH
YEAH YEAH
YEAH
THE PROCESS YEAH YEAH
OUR
YEAH
-- YEAH --
MISTER YEAH YOU
GUYS ARE -- LINE --
OKAY -- OKAY --
YEAH YEAH
YEAH
YEAH RIGHT
--
YEAH YEAH YEAH FOR THE BILL
RIGHT YEAH -- --
-- YEAH --
--
YEAH THE -- -- -- --
YEAH UHHUH UHHUH
YOU'RE RIGHT YEAH
YEAH
YEAH BUT YEAH --
THIS IS MORE
WELCOME WELCOME SENATOR STERN
WELCOME SENATOR STERN --
APOLOGIES MADAM CHAIR -- READY
WHEN YOU ARE OKAY SB FOUR OF
SIX OKAY VERY GOOD -- WITH YOUR
INDULGENCE I WANT TO BRIEFLY
I'LL TRUNCATE MY PRESENTATION
-- WE'VE BEEN WORKING A LONG
TIME TO IMPROVE AT CLEAN UP
AND EARN THE TRUST BACK OF CAL
JAM WITH COMMUNITIES LIVING
IN -- AMONGST OIL AND GAS
SITES -- ALL OVER CALIFORNIA
-- THIS BILL WOULD HOPEFULLY
MODERNIZE THEIR MANAGEMENT I
GIVE THEM SOME CLEAR METRICS
AND MARKERS APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND WOULD
PAGE FOUR -- I'M HAPPY TO GET
INTO DETAILS BUT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE INFORMATION
IS AVAILABLE THE PUBLIC THAT
RESIDENTS ARE GIVEN STANDING
A REGARDLESS OF THEIR --
RESIDENTIAL STATUS EVEN IF
YOU LIVE IN AN APARTMENT OR IF
YOU'RE ON A HOUSE OR OTHERWISE
LIVING WITHIN THE RADIUS OF A
WELL -- YOU SHOULD ALSO HAVE
STANDING TO FILE A COMPLAINT
WITH CAL JIM -- AND -- THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF OTHER ELEMENTS
IN HERE THAT WE THINK WILL MAKE
THIS DATABASE COMPREHENSIVE
TRANSPARENT TO THE PUBLIC
AND HOPEFULLY EARN THE TRUST
BACK OF THE CALIFORNIA PEOPLE
-- IN REGULATING FUELING
GAS INDUSTRY -- I HAVE AN
ALEXANDER WITHIN OUR DC AND
LAUREN COLEMAN WITH THE SIERRA
CLUB INSPECT THE ABSTRACT
THANK YOU A MODERATOR
KEY PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ONE MOMENT
GOOD MORNING DAN ALEXANDER CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE GO AHEAD
-- GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AND AND ALEXANDER
WITH THAT NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL EIGHTY FOUR
OH SIX REPRESENTS AN IMPORTANT
STEP TOWARD MAKING COLLAGEN
THAT BETTER AND MORE EFFECTIVE
AGENCY THAT LEGISLATURE
THE GOVERNOR AND ULTIMATE
BOB OPEN ABOUT THE NEED FOR
CONTINUED REFORM IN LIGHT OF
THE MAGNITUDE OF CALIFORNIA'S
OIL INDUSTRY AND ITS IMPACT
ON CALIFORNIANS WHO LIVE
YOU'RE TELLING OPERATIONS
ESSENTIAL TO ANY REFORM AFTER
IS TRANSPARENCY WHICH IS WHERE
AT THE FOUR O'CLOCK COMES INTO
WHO IN DURING THE IMPACT OF
OIL DRILLING OPERATIONS NEED
TO HAVE THE FULL ABILITY TO
UNDERSTAND LIBERATION AND
THAT INCLUDES THE ABILITY TO
REVIEW PERMITTING DOCUMENTS
AN INSPECTION REPORT CONCEALED
RECORDS AND OTHER TYPES OF KEY
INFORMATION ABOUT THE WEALTH
STATE LET BLACK SB FOUR SIX
ALSO TAKES STEPS TO STREAMLINE
COORDINATION BETWEEN CAL JAM
IN THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHO
ALSO PLAY A ROLE IN REGULATING
OIL DRILLING OPERATION THE
PROPOSAL WILL HELP THESE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS COMMUNICATE
WITH THEIR COULD GET YOU
AND AND WELL INTENTIONALLY
FACILITATE INCLUSION OF LOCAL
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS AND
CAL JAM RECORDS AND FINALLY
LAST BUT NOT LEAST AS THE
SENATOR ALLUDING TO THE CUT THE
PROPOSAL MARKS THE IMPORTANT
RECOGNITION THAT MANY PEOPLE
LIVING NEAR AND EXTRACTED BY
DRILLING OPERATIONS ARE NOT
LANDOWNERS IT WOULD ENSURE THAT
ANYBODY LIVING WITHIN A MILE OF
A WELL AND INSTEAD GET Q.
IT'S VERY WELL DOCUMENTED
HEALTH IMPACT HAS THE
RIGHT TO SUBMIT A COMPLAINT
CAL JAM ABOUT IT AND HAVE
IT INVESTIGATED WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE CENTER
STERN SPEARHEADING THIS
COMMONSENSE PROPOSAL AND
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR EYES OUT
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
HI GOOD MORNING AGAIN THIS IS
A MORE IN CALLING ON BEHALF
OF SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING HALF MILLION
MEMBERS AND SUPPORTERS ACROSS
THE GATE CARE COOK CALIFORNIA
SUPPORTS SD FOR A SIX BECAUSE
THE BILL WILL INCREASE
PUBLIC TRANSPARENCY IMPROVE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND HELP PERFORM
CAL CHEN FOR DECADES CALDERON
HAS HAD A POOR REPUTATION AMONG
PUBLIC HEALTH ENVIRONMENTAL
ACTIVISTS IN GAZA MUST
TRANSFORM ITSELF BEING AGENCIES
AND REGAIN THE PUBLIC TRUST AT
THE CORE OF THIS WILL HELP WITH
THAT TRANSFORMATION AGENCY HAS
BEEN HISTORICALLY NON THANK
INCREASING TRANSPORT UNITS
MAKING DATA AND INFORMATION
EQUITABLE ACCOUNTABLE TO THE
PUBLIC EXPRESSION OF MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC THAT ARE LIVING
NEXT DOOR TO ON ACTIVITIES AND
THREATENED BY THE ATTENTION
PROFIT ADDITION DURING THE
GREAT YOU COULD NOT HAVE
HAD IN A RAPID PROJECTS TO
HELP IMPLEMENT ENFORCEABLE
IMPROVEMENT CONVENTIONAL
IMPORTANT ALTHOUGH THERE'S A
LOT OF WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE TO ENSURE ENFORCEMENT
A CONCERTED OUTREACH EFFORTS
TO INCREASE COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN THE STATE AND LOCAL
AGENCIES ESPECIALLY THOSE
REPRESENTING IS NOT IMPACTED
WILL HELP HOW MANY CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS AND NEGATIVE IMPACT
OF ALL ACTIVITIES THE CRIMINAL
LOCAL COMMUNITY RESIDENTS
HAVE A RIGHT MISTREATMENT
OF PETITIONS THE COMPLAINT
ABOUT HIM GOING ON OR NOT
WELL THE RESIDENT ONE NOT TO
BREATHE IN THE DIRTY EMISSIONS
FROM DIESEL I GOT PROBLEMS
AFTER THE HEALTH IMPACT OF
JUST AS MUCH OF A RIGHT IF
NOT MORE TO ASK FOR SUCH AN
INVESTIGATION FOR THESE REASONS
YOUR CALL CALIFORNIA SUPPORT
THAT BEFORE THANK YOU THINK
SENATORS DEMOCRAT LEADERSHIP
ON THIS ISSUE AND WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU THAT'S WE HAVE AND
ONE WITNESS REGISTERED IN
OPPOSITION ACREE LEERY FROM
THE WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
AGUIAR-CURRY WITH THE LESSON
SAID PATROLLING ASSOCIATION WE
HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON AS BEFORE -- SIX
WE UNDERSTAND THE AUTHOR'S
INTENT TO ENSURE ACCURATE DATA
AND TRANSPARENCY WE'VE BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY CLOSELY WITH
DOCTORS OFFICE INSURE THAT SB
FOUR SIX WORKABLE IN PRACTICE
AND WE SUBMITTED AMENDMENT
THAT WE THINK WOULD ADDRESS
OUR CONCERNS ARE AMENDMENTS
WOULD SIMPLY BRING CLARITY TO
A FEW SECTIONS OF THE BILL AND
MIGHT HELP EASE SOME MINISTRY
TO BURDEN -- CREATED BY SOME
OF THE LANGUAGE IN ADDITION
TO PROVIDING CLARIFICATION
ON THE INTENT SCOPE OF THE
BILL -- WE DO APPRECIATE THAT
SENATOR STERN ACCEPTED ONE
OF OUR MEN IN THE SENATE THE
NEW YORK THEM SHOULD THE BILL
PASS UNFORTUNATELY UNTIL IT
CONCERNS ARE ADDRESSED WILL
REMAIN CLOSED AMENDED THANKS
FOR YOUR HELP TODAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL MOVE TO
WITNESSES ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION I
DIDN'T OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES RELATING
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OR SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE OH NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
RIGHT -- THIS IS LYNN PLAN BACK
SANTA CLARITA ORGANIZATION FOR
PLANNING AND THE ENVIRONMENT IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
WE ARE LIVING NEXT TO A LARGE
GAS STORAGE FACILITY AND THEY
HAVE A NEW HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
ON TOP OF AN OIL FIELD IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT PEOPLE
HAVE ACCESS TO INFORMATION
THANK YOU PLEASE VOTE YES
NINE NINETY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD
MORNING COMMITTEE ERIC ROMAN
FROM POSITIONS PROPOSAL
POSSIBLY LOS ANGELES -- HAVING
WORKED FOR OVER A DECADE WITH
UNIQUE LIVING CAN FINALLY GOT
THE SOVIET MY PANELS -- WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL --
FOR OIL INDUSTRY ACCOUNTABILITY
TRANSPARENCY THANK YOU
LINE FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
THIS IS JANET PARKS FOR THREE
FIFTY THOUGHT KERN VALLEY
AND ELDERS CLIMATE ACTION
BOTH NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU LINE EIGHTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD YEAH MORNING
THIS IS HOW I'M CURRENTLY
SPEAKING FOUR ZERO NINE
FIRST WE THANK ALL AND GAPS
COUNTY STRONGLY IN FAVOR
AND THANK YOU ALL THE STAFF
THANK YOU LINE NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD MORNING
CATHY SCHAEFER REPRESENTING
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
CLIMATE REALITY PROJECT
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU LINE EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD MORNING
COMMITTEE THIS IS DIANA WINANS
CHAIR OF THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY CHAPTER OF CLIMATE
REALITY IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF FIFTY FOUR SIX THANK YOU
THANK YOU I'M WHITE
I'M STRAIGHT LINE SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO THIS IS THE LEAST BOND
EQUITY CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THERE ARE
THERE ARE NO FURTHER LINES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION PLEASE
CONTINUE MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS CAN I WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE YES THANK YOU I JUST
WOULD SAY ONE THING IN THE
CLOSE -- THE DATES THAT WE
PROVIDED IN THE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN THIS COMMITTEE I WANT
TO BE CLEAR THAT AS THE AS THE
ANALYSIS NOTES -- ON PAGE FOUR
-- WE WANT THIS INFORMATION
BE MADE PUBLIC -- WE'VE GIVEN
AT SOME FIRM DEADLINES BUT
THERE'S NOTHING PREVENTING
CAL JIM FROM GETTING THIS
INFORMATION BACK ONLINE RIGHT
NOW AND WE THINK THAT THEY
SHOULD AT LEAST RESTORE WHAT
USED TO BE ON THEIR WEBSITE
OF A BUNCH OF WELL RECORDS
THAT ARE SUDDENLY NOW NOT ON
THAT WEBSITE AND I'VE SORT
OF INEXPLICABLY FALLEN OUT --
STILL LIKE THAT TO BE REMEDIED
IMMEDIATELY SO I DON'T WANT
THIS BILL TO BE MISINTERPRETED
AS SORT OF BUYING THEM TIME
-- IN THAT IN THAT EFFORT FOR
THE NEAR TERM DATA MAKING THE
PRIORITIZATION LANGUAGE IN THE
BILL HELPS ACCOMPLISH THAT I'M
I'LL JUST SAY IN CLOSING --
EVERY RESIDENT DOESN'T MATTER
IF YOU OWN A HOME SHOULD HAVE
A RIGHT TO KNOW WHAT'S GOING
ON IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD AND
NOT JUST WHERE THE WELL IS BUT
WHAT THE HISTORY THAT WELL AS
AND IF IT DOESN'T NOTICE IN
A RECORD OF VIOLATIONS THAT
HAVEN'T BEEN ENFORCED SHE
HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW THAT SO
THIS BILL HOPEFULLY RESTORE
SOME OF THAT TRANSPARENCY
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR THANK YOU
SENATOR WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA SECONDED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI
-- THE MOTION IS DUE PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL ONE ITEM
ELEVEN SB FOUR ZERO SIX BY
SENATOR STERN MEMBERS RIVAS
HI RIVERSIDE FLORA FLOOR NOT
VOTING CHAU FRIEDMAN GARCIA
GARCIA I MATHIS MCCARTY WROTE
TO TREAT MURATSUCHI I SAY ARE
TO THEY ARE TURNOUT VOTING
STONE STONE I WOULD WOOD I FIVE
ZERO FIVE ZERO THANK YOU NEXT
IS THE FINAL ITEM ITEM THIRTEEN
-- SB FOUR TWENTY THREE VERY
GOOD -- MANAGER MEMBERS SB FOUR
TWENTY THREE WELL HOPEFULLY PUT
CALIFORNIA ON TRACK TO BUILD
A MORE RESILIENT GRID BUT THE
CALIFORNIA WAY NOT TO REVERT
BACK TO A TEXAS STYLE APPROACH
WHERE WE ISLANDERS SELVES AND
PUSH OUT RENEWABLE RESOURCES
AND DOUBLE DOWN ON A FOSSIL
FUEL INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN TO TO
GET THROUGH THE CLIMATE CRISIS
BUT USE A DIVERSE BALANCE OF
-- FIRM ZERO CARBON RESOURCES
TO GET THAT DONE AND AND WITH
THAT -- SORT OVERALL PURVIEW
OF THE BILL ONE EXCEPT THE
REVISIONS OF THAT DEFINITION OF
FIRMS YOU'RE A CARBON RESOURCES
AS NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS AS
WELL AS A VETTING COMMENT
THREE AND THEN ON PAGE FIVE
COMMENTS FOR ONE -- EXCEPT --
THE USE OF DEVELOPMENT IN THE
PLACE OF PROCUREMENT AT THE
CLEAR FRONT THE C.
E.
C.
ASSESSMENT IN THIS BILL
I WHICH IS THE LAST
REMAINING PIECE AFTER SOME
PROVISIONS WERE REMOVED IN
UTILITIES AND COMMERCE TO
REMOVE SOME OF THE I.
O.
U.
OPPOSITION AT THE C.
C.
ASSESSMENT IS NOT INTENDED TO
TO SORT OF TAKE THE PLACE OF A
MANTA PROCUREMENT MANDATE HERE
SO I HAVE BEEN GETTING MORE
DETAILS BUT I THINK THIS IS A
GREENER WAY TO AVOID BLACKING
OUT AND UP WITH IT BUT THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I.
PHONE THANK YOU I'M WILL GO
AHEAD AND MOVE TO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT MODERATOR KEEP PLEASE
OPEN UP THE LINES I HAVE JOHN
WHITE FROM THE CLEAN POWER
CAMPAIGN AND DAN JACOBSON
FROM ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA
SH GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS JOHN WHITE
REPRESENTED THE CLEAN POWER
CAMPAIGN -- WHERE THE SPONSORS
OF THIS BILL AND US HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT -- AS WE'VE
GOT MORE EXPERIENCE -- WITH
THE TRANSITION TO A LOW CARBON
GRID WE DISCOVERED THE NEED TO
BROADEN THE TECHNOLOGIES THAT
WE CONSIDER IN OUR PLANNING AND
-- PARTICULARLY FOCUS ON THOSE
THAT HAVE THE ATTRIBUTES THAT
THE GROWTH MOST NEEDS ONE OF
THOSE MOST IMPORTANT ATTRIBUTES
IN ADDITION TO ZERO CARBON IS
FIRM RESOURCES WHICH CAN BE
AVAILABLE AFTER THE SUN GOES
DOWN AND BEFORE THE SUN COMES
UP SO THERE ARE A VARIETY OF
TECHNOLOGIES THAT -- ARE ARE
COMING ALONG AND DESERVE TO
BE -- CONSIDERED AND SO THE
ASSESSMENT BY THE CDC WE THINK
WILL AID THE END OF BROADENING
OUR TECHNOLOGY OPTIONS IN
BETTER UNDERSTANDING THE PATH
FORWARD SO THAT WE CAN HAVE AN
AFFORDABLE CLEAN AND RELIABLE
GRID WE ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE
NEXT WITNESS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BUT I'M
SURE MY NAME IS DAN JACOBSON
WITH BERMAN CALIFORNIA WE'RE
SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL --
QUICKLY WHAT WE WANT TO DO
IS TO MOVE TOWARD A HUNDRED
PERCENT THAT THEIR RIGHTS
SPEECH -- THE LAW OBVIOUSLY
SAID THAT WE HAVE TO GET THERE
BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE BUT THE
CLIMATE IMPACTS THAT WE'RE
SEEING RIGHT NOW SAY THAT WE'RE
PROBABLY GONNA NEED TO MOVE
THERE AT A MORE RAPID PACE
AND THE REASON WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL IS BECAUSE THIS GIVES US
MORE TOOLS IN THE TOOLBOX TO
LOOK AT THE DIFFERENT EFFECTIVE
WAYS THAT WE CAN MOVE TOWARD
A HUNDRED PERCENT IN A SMART
WAY WE ARE STILL USING A LOT
OF THE OLD DEFINITIONS --
FROM WHEN WE WERE GENERATING
POWER WITH FOSSIL FUELS AS A
WAY IN WHICH TO BOXES AND WHEN
WE THINK ABOUT THE KINDS OF
ENERGY THAT WE NEED AND THIS
BILL TAKES A REALLY SMART AND
PRACTICAL APPROACH TO WORKING
WITH THE AGENCIES HERE IN
THE STATE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE CAN LOOK AT CLEAN ENERGY
RESOURCES LIKE OFFSHORE WIND
OR LIKE LONG DURATION STORAGE
AND FIGURE OUT THE DIFFERENT
WAYS TO COMBINE THEM TOGETHER
SO WE SUPPORT THIS BILL IS A
PRACTICAL STEP MOVING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION ENCOURAGING
NOT GO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU WE HAVE ONE
WITNESS REGISTERED IN
OPPOSITION ANTHONY SAMPSON
FROM THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC POWER AUTHORITY
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS -- ANTHONY SAMPSON
ON BEHALF OF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC POWER
AUTHORITY I JUST WANT TO
THANK -- THAT COMMITTEE AND
-- PER THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
AS WELL AS -- THE SENATOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO TAKE THEM
WITH THAT REPLACEMENT -- THE
WORD PROCUREMENT FOR THE WORD
DEVELOPMENT GAP IS PLEASED
TO BE REMOVING ITS OPPOSITION
THANK YOU WE WILL WILL MOVE
TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION ALL START
WITH THOSE IN THE HEARING ROOM
PLEASE GO AHEAD HELLO -- MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AND JUST WANT TO CLARIFY WE ARE
LISTED IN OPPOSITION -- THAT
WAS IN A PREVIOUS VERSION OF
THE BILL THE BILL'S HEADED IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND WE HOPE
THAT WHEN ALL OF THE AMENDMENTS
ARE IN FRANCE WE CAN -- REMOVE
OPPOSITION THANK YOU IN Q.
AND MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES
FOR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
THANK YOU YES IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YEAH GOOD MORNING CHEN MEMBERS
THIS IS GLORIOUS HE MENACE WOOD
COUNTY -- GAS ELECTRIC COMING
OUT OF THE BLACK COMMITTEE WE
WERE -- NEUTRAL WE'RE STILL
LOOKING AT THE WORLD CLARIFY
OUR POSITION AS SOON AS WE
SEE THE BILL IN FRENCH BUT SO
FAR WE FEEL THE BILL PASSED IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION THANK YOU
LINE ONE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD HI THIS IS CAPITAL
BOARD WITH SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON -- SIMILAR TO THE
THE PREVIOUS -- BAKER WE ARE
LOOKING AT THE NEW AMENDMENT
BUT BELIEVE THAT STILL MOVING
IN A POSITION WHERE WE CAN
REMAIN OPPOSED THANK YOU
THANK YOU NINE ONE TWENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD I HAD
TO GO THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES SO TENSION
ONE OUTLINED MY COMMENTS --
WITH ANTHONY SAMPSON PRINCE
KAPPA CREATE WORKING WITH
DOCTORS STAFF AND COMMITTEE
STAFF INSINUATES PLEASE REMOVE
THE PROPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU LINE FIFTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
JANET STRATEGIC CONSULTANT
ALLEY AND THE NORTHERN
AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER THAT ELDERS CLIMATE
ACTION IN SUPPORT THANKS
THANK YOU LINE EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YES THIS IS A
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS THIS
IS DIANA WINE AND -- CHAIR OF
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY CHAPTER
CLIMATE REALITY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU LINE ONE TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD SH ZERO
WE'D REPRESENTING THREE FIFTY
BAY AREA ACTION IN THE COURT
THANK YOU LINE ONE
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD MORNING CATHY SCHAEFER
REPRESENTING SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY CLIMATE REALITY
PROJECT IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU NINE SEVENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
-- LIKE TOM RYAN MCCARTHY
WITH THE VITAMIN GROUP ON
BEHALF OF FORM ENERGY SUPPORT
THANK YOU THERE ARE NO FURTHER
LINES IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
CONTINUE READING CHECK THANK
YOU ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE YOU SEE NOT A
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE SENATOR
THANK YOU REALLY APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE'S WORK ON THIS
-- AND WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL THANK YOU I HAVE A
MOTION FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FLORA SECONDED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MURATSUCHI THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON NINE
ONE THIRTEEN SB FOUR TWENTY
THREE BY SENATOR STERN MEMBERS
RIVAS HI RIVAS III FLORA FLORA
I CHAU FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I
GARCIA GARCIA I MATHIS MCCARTY
WROTE TO TREAT MURATSUCHI I
SAY ARE TOLD HI THEY ARE TOO
I STONE STONE I WOULD I WOULD
I'D NINE ZERO NINE ZERO THAT
BILLS OUT BUT WE'LL LEAVE IT
OPEN THANK YOU CENTER THANK
YOU CERTAIN EIGHT ZERO SORRY
ABOUT THAT -- EIGHT ZERO
RIGHT SO
YEAH -- BUT I THINK
YEAH GO AHEAD
YEAH THAT'S PRETTY
THE BILL SO LOADS OF SO
WHERE WE'RE READY FOR ADD
ONS TO ALL OF THE BILLS
AND THE CONSENT CALENDAR --
SOME BILLS THAT ARE ON CALL
WITH -- WE HAVE SOME BILLS
ON CALL I THINK WE CAN JUST
GO THROUGH THE THE ONCOLOGY
IN ORDER WE LIVE CHAU
WOOD OKAY MCCARTY IS HERE
LET'S GO IN ORDER AND
THE CONSENT CALENDAR ALSO
-- THE CONSENT CALENDAR KERBAL
IS SIX TWO ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS
CHAU CHOW I FRIEDMAN ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR CONSENT
CALENDAR FRIEDMAN I MCCARTY
MCCARTY I MURATSUCHI FIVE
MURATSUCHI I WOULD WOOD I
ELEVEN ZERO TEN ELEVEN ZERO
THAT ONE'S OUT ON ITEM TO SB
THIRTY SEVEN CORTESE MOTION IS
TO PASS REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE FIVE
TO ONE WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
I ABSENT MEMBERS FRIEDMAN
ON ITEM TO SB THIRTY SEVEN
YES THEY ARE NOT VOTING
FRIEDMAN NOT VOTING
MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE
MURATSUCHI HI MURATSUCHI
I WOULD WOULD NOT VOTING
SEVEN ZERO SEVEN
ZERO THAT PHYLLIS OUT
OKAY FINE ITEM THREE SB SIX
THREE NINETY SIX SENATOR
DOLLY MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE SIX
ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS CHILD
CHAU AYE FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI SORRY YOU
GOT IT HI ROB TO GI WOOD
WHAT I ELEVEN ZERO ELEVEN
ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT
ONE ITEM SEVEN SB FOUR FIFTY
SIX BY SENATOR LAYERED TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE SEVEN ZERO
ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU CHOW I
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI I WOULD WOULD I A
LEVEL ZERO ELEVEN ZERO THAT
BILLS OUT I AM EIGHT SB THREE
SEVENTY TWO BY LEYVA TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE FIVE
ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS FLORA
FLORA I'D CHAU CHOW I FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN I MCCARTY MCCARTY
AYE STONE STONE I WOULD WHAT I
LOVE IN ZERO ELEVEN ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT I DON'T NINE SB
FORTY SEVEN BY SUNDAY LIMóN DO
PASSED REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE
SIX TO TWO WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ABSENT MEMBERS
FLORA FLORIDA NOT VOTING
MCCARTY MCCARTY I WOOD
WOOD I OKAY EIGHT TWO
EIGHT TWO APPLE IS OUT
YEAH I DON'T TURN SB EIGHTEEN
BY SENATOR SKINNER TO PASS
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE KERR ABOUT EIGHT TO
ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS FLORA FLORA
I MCCARTY MCCARTY I WOULD WOULD
IS LEVIN ZERO ELEVEN ZERO THAT
BILLS OUT I AM ELEVEN US BEFORE
-- SIX UNDER CERTAIN TO PASS AS
AMENDED REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE FIVE TO
ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS CHILD CHAU
AYE FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I MATHIS
MCCARTY MCCARTY I
EIGHT ZERO EIGHT
ZERO THAT PULLS OUT
IDM THIRTEEN US BEFORE TWENTY
THREE BY SENATOR STERN TO
PASS AS AMENDED REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE EIGHT TWO ZERO
ABSENT MEMBER CHILD SHALL I
MATHIS MCCARTY MCCARTY I TEN
ZERO TEN ZERO THAT BILLS OUT
THAT'S OKAY OKAY MEETING
IS ADJOURNED THANK YOU